so all right
mike check what's going on lords in the
round what's going on
showing the levels is good you know the
routine hustling motivate what's going
on philly eagle what's going on
sifu poetic ex-initiative what's going
on
rob c talk to me let me know how the
levels are sounding
what's going on thank you brother how's
that motivate you know what i'm saying
we got it's a lot of dmv representations
last uh two three iops you're gonna be
happy man
what's going on other zinc what's up man
gamer by
choice one of my favorites thank you rob
see what's going on
phantom kraken you know what i mean
what's going on new name
gaff gaff gary what's going on man
haven't seen you before
salute sean zoo what's up what's up so
yeah we're just waiting for um i'm gonna
get fc up in here
have some fun oh forte what's going on
brother
oh okay okay you show the crib yeah
hustle we gotta we
yo we're doing our like we're doing our
dmv tour right now man we're doing a dmv
we're hitting everybody up and that's in
the dmv
you was you was one of the early ones
yeah
what's going on sex slayer my man the
audio visual
lord yeah i'm waiting on that um that
joint that uh
about my sound ball you know i'm saying
thank you for the for the um to join
though i really appreciate it
we're gonna get attic up in here i don't
know he i think he in the bushes he was
up late last night
i know king was watching the fights so
you know he gonna have a lot to say
this song should be coming through so
yeah i'll get uh
violent in here in a minute and we're
gonna have some fun today y'all
know stop being messy about patches i
see you i see
you ready you got your gun [ __ ] i
already see what you are
anyway let me get up out of here we just
wanna do this real quick and then uh
we'll get fc in the crew and you already
know the king is soft
pulling up with attic i'm gonna talk to
all right and we are
live welcome to the iron lords podcast
and also live on lords of gaming.net
episode number
186 it's another glorious sunday we're
back at the round table on the lord's
day
i'm very excited about our special guest
and we've got phil spencer's version of
you
ps5 gpu issues and assassin's creed stop
laughing assassin's creed violent
patches
don't don't stop laughing keep oh yeah
they ain't gonna like me today we're
gonna talk about filmmaking decree we're
gonna talk
i don't care about that i'm gonna
introduce the lord
we're not only passionate about the art
form that is video games but also
appreciates the intricacies involved in
their making
whether it be his insightful takes on
the gaming industry or engaging in
multi-platform debate
he always manages to keep it gaming
introducing the creating host of the fc
violent youtube channel and the host of
the vitamin g
podcast the lord of not hating on games
until he plays them
yet will still dawn those black gloves
with his
console hunting season
live from the dmv and making his debut
long-awaited debut into the realm of the
lords
my man lord fc violet how are we doing
sir
yo what up baby what's going on youtube
what's going on
chad what's going on panel man it's an
honor to be
here man absolutely how to put like a
shea butter on my ankles
for so long man i was like okay
if you run out i ship it out to you
don't forget
a little bit man but you know what shout
out to my guy a little cognito and
everybody in the past
i can't wait to get to these topics man
appreciate you brother man long overdue
man can't wait have you been getting a
chance to play anything sir what you
been what you been getting into man
i've been playing ac valhalla man but
because because because i how my
situation is i can't i couldn't get the
console so i got to do it on pc
just don't put to keep the black gloves
away and the masking wave i know it's
the season
keep that mask on make sure that you run
out and you purchase one of our neck
gators
use that mask to get both consoles don't
just get one right
every night when i go on that walmart or
the ps5 direct or whatever and i get
that
it's already sold out i walk by my
closet and look at my black forces like
man
i just i just got one thing to say
that's an iron lord's podcast
exactly thank you thank you we didn't we
didn't hear nothing we didn't
he said what addict really said was not
all of us of iron lord
i'm i'm the malcolm x by any means don't
make me start
saying that our beliefs isn't what kings
don't lose yourself
good morning to you sir yes yes let's
put the crest in the chat for michael
leskew junior lord bronze welcome to the
realm my brother thank you
awesome and we have squirrely dance
showing off
on twitter i see you've got brick
problems i feel
bad for you son i got 99 problems with
ps580
that's what
but squirrely man you got to get those
little nif nod uh statues
oh wow and put a real statue buy his
ticket to my raffle
to get get get a real stat you see them
you see them get a real statue get it
out of that squirrel
man i'm pulling up already know and
of course we got the four horsemen of
gaming those original lords of the realm
here at the round table
my co-host with the coach my brother
from another mother the difficult game
conqueror
lord of his own world and the how of the
young wolf
my man lord addict how we doing sir
doing pretty good uh
you know first thing i want to say is
you know i i was gonna i was gonna do a
little man talk but uh yeah it's too
early for that i'm tired so
i'm not doing that this morning people
just uh keep my name at your mouth
that's all
okay what's going on
i i gotta call out kid smooth uh-oh so
we uh there's this game on game pass
called star render games i'm sure you
guys have seen me talk about it on
twitter
this game is amazing and i
bring it up to kmega and kiss luke tell
me how these people gonna look at this
game
if you look man look at that look how
this game looks
wow like this this you want me to play
my
series x with this and i was just like
oh just like oh
so not not now it's about how a game
looks okay got you so it's got to look a
certain way before you're willing to try
it
i gotta give respect to addict because
he called me on the phone yo he he
called i said i thought
every time adam called me i think
something happened
he called me on the phone and i'm like
i'm ready to ride i'm putting on my
black air force one
what's up man what happened i'm putting
my neck gator on i'm like what happened
and he like yo that star renegade when
you said it
you know i didn't i thought it was still
on pc but now that it's on console
yo he said yo i've been blazing like 30
hours
i said damn man this dude didn't pass me
already he just got
he's like jamie he's like he does it i
uh
can't tell him nothing i finally beat it
and it took me almost 70 hours
wow because it's one of those things
where it resets every
every time you play it where did you get
so many hours
i've been playing a week and a half out
here getting exotics while you're on a
podcast
i totally respect his hustle and that
game like for anybody to sit there
and just take it off of what it looks
like first of all the art direction is
amazing
it's uh it's it's 16-bit to 32-bit
graphics right
in 2d format and what it's
doing for what it gives you sound art
design
music playability and for for the game
it is
it's amazing it's truly the only
the only uh you know criticism i can get
for you know shout out to
to massive games uh they actually hit me
up on twitter
it's just like you know that the game is
so unique it's
it's it's such a good game i i i
recommend everyone in the chat
trying it out i'm just going to say one
quick it's like
it's like a tur it's it's it's the best
turn-based combat i've ever seen
the uh you know it doesn't really got a
story because it's
it's kind of like what dead cells was
where everything is generated every day
every time you play and every time you
play it you pretty much have to you have
to liberate three planets of
all these enemies and it's like i said
it's it's a uh it's a turd-based game
but after every planet you get random
two people that show up and you get to
recruit them to your team
and by the time you get to the end of
the game man you have all these
these nice people but the thing is is
when they give you new people they're
like yo bring this
bring the bad people come on bring more
of them so it's a good game and i have
to recommend everyone to try it that's
what's up yo
you want to get the judge before we get
you in here oh and it's not on
playstation sorry chris racist
i mean sorry
anytime i talk about any game you know
you already picked it over
all right exactly
yeah we have [ __ ] with the five dollar
super chat sending love to the show
making my little girl yell time
also pink kimbo
from
salute to the og's man yo mad love your
salute to game on
all day i was on there yesterday with
kiss move and it's separate goes man
shout out to aside all that
yeah it's it's a good one one show
really good show support their brothers
man they really do what they think
and definitely guys being you going to
work so look out for that
call 12 o'clock okay yeah 12
o'clock okay what's the next one yeah
and we have
108 dragons tv with the five dollar
super chat good morning to the lords and
shout out to fc what's good fam
for the ps5 gpu subject and happy
belated turkey day facts
yo 108 when you hit me up last night i
was in the middle of something sorry
then we got betty smith with the five
dollar super chat opponent to nate
robinson
stand still while you catch this
nightbook
right now we're gonna talk about that
we're gonna talk about that
there we go michael askew junior with
the five dollar super chat my bad
a member but that nate robinson ko had
knocked my membership off
then we have shane tomlin with the five
pound super chat i need to say sorry to
all you ps users out there i paid off
ubisoft not phil and i loved it the book
of acts
and the person who was introducing those
uh super chats was the most technical
gaming lord
the solo gamer list with a single player
selfish experience and also
the sastradamus the lord of clarity and
patreon of the iron bank
my man lord sanford how are we doing sir
i'm doing well man i'm doing very good
oh this is my last day of vacation
set my vacation right i have chris i
have christmas vacation coming up but it
it sucks to know i gotta get up at four
in the morning so i was like
all it takes is a week for you to get
out of your zone that's all it takes
you know it's funny is all uh in the
past like two
probably two months i've had two
vacations
because i just because i already got my
new one and they made me take my old one
at the very end of it because i i have a
problem of never taking vacations on
vacation
we got all right we're going to move
forward microwave
finance for two dollars good morning
lords hope all is well okay so before we
move forward i have to do something
last week king said that he had me and i
was like
what is that you gonna live with that he
didn't want it no he won
he didn't want to do it on the show and
i respect that but you know what if i
got to get smoked i could get smaller
the the thing you had me on last week
crazy in this chat don't do it it's not
fine because i have to admit what
happened to me as well
yes right
listen the playstation playstation is
having some issues
so he tries to play his disc of avengers
and it doesn't recognize and says you
better pay me to
download this game which is exactly what
he said was to happen right
obviously it's a glitch but i got to eat
that because that's not the fight
this is what happened to me right i went
in
and i i have all digital right so
there's two games in my library
that do not appear and they're like
you've got to cop this it's kids
and one of them is ghosts yeah so no my
ghost is fine but what didn't work for
me is
uncharted lost legacy oh no and shadow
of the colossus and i'm like
i purchased these games and they're not
there and so the thing is i'm like okay
i game share with kaibatsu so maybe
that's it
but then i look at those games i'm like
those are not games he would purchase
right the only the only games he would
lead purchase on in our playstation
library would be persona 5
and spiderman beyond that everything
else i like i'm gonna cop that right
right so it's just not there it's gone
wow
try to play that game i said let me see
how this uncharted lost legacy looks
it was like 19.99
so i'm gonna do this right now you're
gonna laugh too because my desk is mad
high so i'm probably gonna
appear his head is gonna disappear
so again again you know king king gave
me these last week because
they indeed do have back compat however
broken it is yes
so but i had to give these knees because
that was funny
i'm like are you kidding me are you
kidding me
wow that was funny
that was funny um so beyond that uh yeah
so um real quick yeah i beat miles
finally um
listen how long did it take you five
hours if you don't mean
i i gotta try to get everything so it
took me a little longer that's seven
okay seven hours great dlc right the the
gameplay cannot be touched the gameplay
the mobility
all of that cannot be touched right i'm
just a little bit mad with a couple of
things
after a while playing the game i can't
stand miles's voice
he's 17 years old and he sounds like he
hasn't hit puberty yet like
i can't stand his voice so that's one
thing put that aside
um and just the like the trophy stuff
like
why do all these heroes have close
friends that are psychopaths like why is
that
like it's just this the story thing that
they do with superheroes all
the time that it's just like i could
have gone different with it i didn't
like him
he turned into a straight sim like at
some point in time you gonna stop
hitting me in my face
you gonna stop taking me to the brink of
death and i'm not going to give you this
spidey charge
and this is the thing and this you know
the thing about it is right he has
something to tell her
for for a good part of the game and at
no point in time like
just just say the words get it out of
your mouth like good cause
like and then at the end she's like
hustling [ __ ]
no spoilers those boys all right let me
let me just take your five hours and
play it
playstation sorry about that how bad
yeah
they're probably having a hard time
getting the playstation to work to play
it so
yeah all right let's forget about it
it's very trophy and
that pissed me off but beyond that like
gameplay is untouchable fantastic no
doubt no doubt hustling
i'm on the last minute mission damn it
let me get through it
first time ever so yeah man that was
horrible though
and then what i went into my um
my history yeah yeah it's not there
either
oh i know when you call when you call
sony you can't even [ __ ]
because they like it's
and yesterday real quick i was erasing
my consoles to trade them in or whatever
and i hadn't done that yet so why does
the playstation take five hours
now you gotta do a regular one don't do
that one yeah yeah that one
there's like a quick eraser there's a
regular race or whatever yeah
i haven't done it yet i don't know where
did you go game stop you gonna go to
gamestop 200.
that was my plan yeah okay don't erase
them they don't care about that
they say just just drop it off just like
that just make sure you have a password
running around yeah you can't have the
dudes running around
no [ __ ] i have a password in my joint
and i never put no uh credit card on
playstation ever
hey he's getting this white
flags so that's what it saw that's it
that's it no doubt and of course we have
the incredible hulk of this aka
the access gamer the prophet of
xbox king of the statues demands nothing
less than that premium experience
it is a leader of the fraud alert
movement
beloved lord king how we doing sir i'm
doing better than nate
i'm
first of all we should have known it was
coming because he got hit with two
thunderous shots to the back of the head
and the boy fell down twice the same way
so nick jonas just doubled in
and just said you know what i'm gonna
turn the beat around
when he hit him in the back of the head
he leaned him so crazy
when he hit the floor and you got snoop
dogg going oh god
oh god yo first thriller
thriller had the best commentators yes
yeah they they told them
smoke weed curse and get into it we
don't care
and if something happened early snoop
you got to perform
yo did you see you're singing precious
lord oh
yo
take me
it was such an amazing
fight just just how quick it was it was
so great but you know
to to get to the main event let's get
into it
first i want to salute roy jones really
i want to salute
grandpa roy he took some body shots
though
he took a lot of stuff he took a lot of
mike hit him in the face and the neck
and
all over um i thought roy was going to
pass away
i thought roy was going to get hit with
something
and he was going to look like nick
cannon um oh so
nick rob
and i thought roy was going to look like
that yesterday
roy stood his ground
through his combos because there were
some points in that fight you saw
flashes of roy
roy with the triple combinations and
turning them
yo he looked
and mike tyson made an eloquent point at
the end what he said
he said why you're worrying about him
dying and not
me dying he just retired three years ago
thanks and i have retired almost 15 or
17 years ago
right i'm a beginner
i'm starting fresh again and and then
you saw the different agendas
yeah right you saw the dif first of all
you saw the different agendas when they
got on their scale
oh yeah so you saw mike tyson
is at a different point in his life
right now when he's trying to create
he's trying to create
a a geritol league yes right so what he
has to do is he has to be if you're
going to
create a geritolig you have to be in
your peak condition
your peak shape and show that the old
can still
you know rise up roy always looked at it
as something on his bucket list yes
so his body reflected yeah
it looked like that it looked like he
had he had the roy gut yeah
and we've never seen roy with a gun
always roy had a 12-pack for his whole
life
so it was kind of anybody that followed
boxing saw it and was like oh damn roy
no man
and then we always thought that oh man
he gonna get caught with one of those
things but roy took these shots
and roy represented boxing
damn good roy at the end said you know
i'm not a draw type of dude
yeah i thought i did enough i thought i
i watched uh holyfield
and linux lures how he they tied him up
and they hold his hand he wasn't gonna
hit me with that uppercut
and i said damn he did exactly what he
set out to do
yeah so salute those two geritol dudes
for getting it in
and um danny jacobs you suck oh
yeah that fight on friday was hot trash
okay
and and and um uh rosario won
um what's your pleasure first what i
want y'all to do right now
because we never say this but it's super
important yes i would like for you guys
if you haven't subscribed and you watch
right now please subscribe
and watch and share it out give it out
to somebody who hasn't heard of us or
somebody you think might like us and
just share it out please this
just you know because i know a lot of
you guys show up yeah
but share sometimes please because it's
the algorithms that
are changing a lot of things that's
going on and i never really paid no
attention to it but it really means some
stuff now
and excuse me cog explained it to me
still getting over this code um kos
tuesday
yes i have two holy grails uh one is in
the back
and i got another one that's coming in
this week um
what i've been playing star renegades
river city girls um
and if y'all didn't know it's been a
silent
update to neon abyss you know that's my
crack
they overhauled all the graphics
okay quiet and they fixed a lot of
things some people was having a problem
with the open the door button being the
same button as your action button
they turn it to your a button so now the
controls make sense
it has a crosshair so you can see where
you're going to shoot
and some of the overlay graphics are
updated so it's it's
just go check it out it changed and it's
a great game
yes oh man that's the big change to
verify
you verify the the uh the originality
no no phil dominus maximus aurelia
spencer has made it easy for me never to
buy nothing
fair enough i'm gonna give a shout out
man shout out to lord paris in the chat
good to see you brother
thank you for pulling up man i love what
you're doing out here salute
you know what i'm saying but that's what
it sir yes that's that's been it man
and uh oh if i got more raffles left i
probably got like three raffles left uh
for this impeccable uh black cat statue
from xm studios
i'm trying to get you guys into premium
collecting 25
uh will get you a 700 to a thousand
dollar type of statue
check it out i mean it's super premium
stuff if you're looking at this stuff
and you're like oh my god i will never
spend a thousand dollars we'll
spend 25. got a shot to win absolutely
you're slow that's the golf castle x
you know what i'm saying we had them on
last week but you already know we got
the gaming ninja himself the shinobi
lord cognito unlocked spreading that
realness and around the iop not telling
you what you want to hear
what you need to hear finally destiny
raid deep stone [ __ ]
is done completed i get my life back
i've been grinding i haven't i haven't
really launched it since i beat it
i need it i need like yo shout out the
power say he though like that destiny
grind
pre-raid takes your soul you know what
i'm saying so salute everybody you know
what i'm saying participated we got it
done shout out to citizen
death singing with the damn we got that
rocket launcher man
i'm waiting for you guys to show up on
consoles december 8th baby xbox series
i'm 60 frames
a little bit just a little bit yes in my
feelings over the death thing yeah
that's just a little bit well
we love you with a clan but we are very
jealous that you got the most rare
let's just put it this way don't use
that with me in your
father's spot you guys don't get the
same stuff
no no no but there's a random driver
there's a five percent chance of you
getting that wrong and the thing about
but the thing that's cool that they've
done now addict that i like is they
taken it to rack to the machine
and which i always thought was the best
system which is if you keep
raiding you get a chance for rewards so
like they had to see the games and that
in this they have these like it's called
like spoils of war like a raid
currency and then you can kind of farm
the
the actual ones that you want you know
what i mean so that part is really cool
the raid is amazing
there's i'm not gonna spoil it for those
who haven't done it yet but there's a
part
after the third encounter where the raid
kind of goes somewhere else
it is the most magical thing bungie's
ever done um
and also shout out to and it's crazy how
they get you back from that other place
shout out right the entire raid is just
extremely well done oh it's well done
shout out to my boy skye lewin again on
the last word we had him on
uh from bungie sound composer mike
salvatore all those guys
the music and destiny is uh man it is
second to none
you've got this thing shout out to you
yesterday with uh
uh thai guy oh yeah
we got to get you in the last word too
brother we see you in there kiss move
what's up baby
what's going on man so anyway so that's
pretty much it man we got a lot of that
stuff
that's all it has been for me i gotta
what's up i got something real quick
before we go all right okay
i was like all right you know huh okay
because
okay just real quick look uh today i'm
gonna i'm gonna be giving a coat away to
the members man so i'm gonna give that
away probably about 1
30. it's gonna be a question so you
might as well get those question glasses
out
okay all right so we got some giveaways
pick it up no
doubt get google ready
i know we have uh smitty smith with the
five dollar super chat
nate didn't get knocked out he's just
looking for his contact lens
he's looking for his eyes
so we all got we good yeah good right no
doubt so now we got into what the lords
have been playing and
fight talk and all that good stuff oh
hold on j dub get jade up
jw is a show oh wait you let me before i
get jw as a show real quick
uh shout out to big mad mo got his
consoles not at the cat daddy uh
finally finally our winners are getting
their consoles jay dubs should be
is a shill should be receiving his
console this week so
shout out to lord jean for helping out
with that amazing
um so yeah thank you guys because we
were we weren't we were looking at
january like maybe
so yeah it's hard to get yeah big man
for putting it up put the pictures up
absolutely
yeah look at that so jw is a [ __ ] with
the five dollar super chat i didn't know
that jesus played video
games why does he have a red beard in
eye glasses
he's loving his series thank you i see
that i see i see the unboxing
i see that you already know yeah so
let's get into this show now we got to
with the laws of plan
you know what i mean let's get you know
focus on lord fc
violet his game system history
you know what i said of course what led
him to create the amazing youtube
channel
and of course that daily dose of the
vitamin c
podcast so lord fc man let's start from
the beginning what are some of the
things that got you into video games
and just what video game systems you had
what got you the gaming yes sir so i had
you know firstly
for you know i have to salute my pops
you know what i mean
so he got me into and got me into gaming
for those who don't know you know i was
born overseas in the philippines you
know i mean manny pacquiao my uncle
shout out shout out to jake panzerelli
as well yeah my filipino brothers yes
sir
yeah so i was over there uh and then he
got me my first console didn't speak
english but over there playing mario and
beating it you know
so what was that eddie that's what was
the first one the any the nes yes
nes with the i think with the duck hunt
right mm-hmm and then
i think the first mario game so that's
what got me into the to the systems and
i was hooked
ever since i was a big nintendo kid uh
i think i had all the nintendo consoles
um so obviously
all of them except for the gamecube
that's that's when things started to
turn from
oh you sound like me yeah you know what
i mean like
i was a nintendo guy until to that
gamecube came out so we were
we got to slap you so what was it that
like turned you
off what what was the the the factors
that led you astray
i mean i grew up man i got older you
know
it's funny because usually not the
gamecube that turns people it's more the
we
than anything else yeah but see i
started earlier it was the game cue that
terrible
yeah i mean so like i so i have uh i
have
two brothers right so i'm the oldest and
then back you know
back then man ain't had no money so we
had to share everything yeah
um so we were playing n64 all that stuff
and then it was
you know it came to a point where pops
was like which i want the new new
consoles come on we got the gamecube we
got the
this new thing called the xbox and then
my brother's younger brothers was like
let's get the gamecube was a hold on
pause
i'm a teenager at this point i'm like
you know i mean i've only played mario
for so long so listen hold on
what is the next console guy i'm looking
at it's more more mature yeah i mean the
graphics was there
and i'm looking at the the gamecube and
i'm like man i don't know
i was like you know what i'm gonna have
to make a executive position
with the xbox first thing my little
brother was like why i'm like nah nah
i'm making a decision we're going with
the x-men
i'm pulling the overwrite code man
what was the what was the factor on xbox
that major the xbox live
i mean i'm looking in like oh we could
play anybody i'm a competitive guy for
those who don't know
and i'm sitting there like okay yeah
like the mecca song and i'm like hey
look
halo did somebody say about something
hey look like halo
yeah so i was hello yeah so we got that
and it was the rest was history man like
when when xbox i think i got pretty i
pretty much get all the consoles but
normally i get like playstation
a little bit later because uh that's
just that's how it always was like xbox
first and i'll get the playstation like
a year or two later
um and then obviously dreamcast as well
which is actually my favorite console of
all time
that's nice yeah they just did things
different man ahead of this time
very ahead of his time very very yeah
you know
salute salute to the dreamcast man r.i.p
all right
yeah it's just serious sir so it's easy
transition too because they you know i
mean
they went to the xbox as well um and
then you know obviously everyone 360 x
yes xbox one give me some standards and
awesome standouts on uh 360.
360. man lost odyssey wow
oh man fire obviously
the halos of course i mean halo 2 came
in 360 right
halo 3 halo 2 was uh
the halo collection has definitely uh
you know changed everybody's
thoughts of when stuff was released
right yeah
360 has some gems though man 360 has
some gems you got um
uh i'm trying to think about trying to
think of another game i played a lot of
different games
i played final fantasy 11 but i know it
was a technically cross play with pc in
the playstation for the first time which
was though
playing against a lot you know pc in the
playstation crowd for those who don't
know absolutely um
dope dope mmo uh mm-hmm
i haven't played play a lot of different
games man mass effect oh let's talk
about it
what's wrong with the first let's switch
oh which one
we got which was the best we got a hater
in the building wait which one's the
first best
which mass makes the best basketball i
don't hate it no i don't hate it i just
want to know which one
which one but everybody knows is the
second
time
i mean the first one's a little taste
and then you obviously
you got a bunch of you work on that
craft and then it makes it a better game
i haven't played the mass effects to
that extent so i have like
no horses when they do that remaster you
gotta jump on the
but to me it feels like the original
mass effect
is more rpg and people like the second
one
because they went away from it a little
bit made a more action orientated
i'm just telling you from what i see he
always kills people for not playing
games before they cover is going to talk
about this i literally just said that i
it's not like i was acting like i
played it it's not like i said hey
cognito i played all of them all right
so what about the playstation i know you
said you would get the xbox consoles
first right
but then you would normally normally
normally but then you still get played
so what was it about the playstation
ecosystem that would still
get you to come on what was some of
those standouts so for me man like even
though i talk a lot of trash
i like to play games and i i don't i'm
not the type of dude that just plays
multiplayer which is like my brothers
they just played nothing but multiplayer
because like i said
we're mad competitive yeah they had to
because i'm the oldest i always you know
i mean
punish them punish them all every day in
the gym yeah they mean working out their
thumbs talking about i'ma have to beat
my big brother but
which they never do but you know they
try anyway salute my brothers man
absolutely yeah but uh yeah it was
always just different experiences man
like oh
so for me like i had the playstation
i think i played the playstation one but
i was like i was pretty young i don't
remember it too well
and i had the playstation 2. um trying
to think of games man but it was hard
times man i didn't have a memory card
so oh you was down one second
yeah man i was doing i mean legacy of
kane
which one did you did you do the blood
omen legacy of king the first one did
you do that one
it was it was the first one of course it
was kane and he died
oh my man that's a classic what would
you do you would leave your console on
and turn your tv
off right and walk out and tell the
people
like i said man i had to put down my
authority
i remember because you know you know how
it is you got game time right like you
die you got to give up the controller
for those who don't know man
i was saying but you know what i mean
like being the oldest you got to kind of
set some rules and you get a little
mulligan's here and there man it's like
no that don't count
that that don't
i remember playing final fantasy 8
i got to the part where you kill uh will
you attempt to kill the soldier for the
first time
and i was wrong with that no memory card
stuff and see i was supposed to get one
the next day because i did
i mowed a bunch of lawns in the previous
day so i'm sitting here like
i'm gonna play this and then i'm gonna
keep it on all right and i'll just put
that memory card in tomorrow and i'll
say
well i came back with the memory card
and i had the playstation you have to
reset for it to register
oh yeah so i'm sitting there i'm looking
at this and
you know it was only like maybe seven
eight hours but back then seven eight
hours was it might as well have been a
lifetime
i was sitting there and i remember
thinking i gotta do this again
yeah because i had to format your memory
card
yeah the playstation always had these
weird here you go
you would do it back then man i played
the first level so many times like
just in case the power go out i'm like
dang i gotta start over
i remember the first day i got my
playstation they didn't have any memory
cards
so i got it and and then i think the
memory cards are like 60 bucks and i was
like i don't want to play with 60 bucks
oh my god i said whatever i got to get
my stuff get home
and then you realize how important it is
and i was like
oh no i can't play like this
so i got my memory cards i got it but i
got a slow fc because saw
we was down with that legacy cave first
of all what was that
hell hail
something happened that they were
supposed to be doing they keep talking
about they're doing it but it just
keeps falling to the waist don't get me
wrong i i didn't mind
the the the eventual sequels where it
became about kane and stuff
but i just felt it lost like yeah i
really
like i really wasn't i know those games
are good and critically acclaimed but
i really like the first one's atmosphere
it was more vampire to me
yeah you would really love
um what what is it uh vampire in the
masquerade
yeah yeah because that is that's what
when when i saw a vampire masquerade
talking about being you know released on
xbox i was like please stay true to the
core
right because that reminds me of the
legacy of king but modern times
but they go they go it's really good but
yeah legacy
is incredible that's right masquerade
i've never played one of those games and
i i'm i'm looking forward to that game i
got to try this
that to me but salute i've seen that
because that was that's a classic i
haven't heard anyone bring that up that
was a classic video yeah i played a lot
of different games man and then like
of course with the playstation as well
finally salute to the you know the ps3
finally you know memory cards and that
became standard you know i mean hard
drive so salute to that
you know but you know mag i don't for
those who don't play mag man that was a
different experience so i'll try that
out
mag was my game man dc universe as well
on the playstation when it was
no no no once i saw those graphics i was
like but see but the thing is though see
like
graphics is cool but for me i i got to
try it out because sometimes you could
overlook it if the gameplay was fun and
i had a so when i played dc universe man
um of course i ran the
servers you know i mean yeah he's not
multi-playing
playing guys don't understand how
competitive it would be so i set up like
a fight
fight ring no oh yeah you know in the
open world so it's like an open world
fight ring so it'll
you do a server chat and be like hey 1v1
who wants it and my you know my name at
the time was king jude
yeah because i'm like listen like
anybody could catch the fade and it was
like
good good versus bad guy right and then
you would just do like
we were trying to win a metropolis for
one of the one of the buildings right it
was like on
on top of like uh um it's like a big big
ring
and i mean like it was like a hundred
feet in there it was a big ring yeah so
i'm like all right
and then the crowd make a circle and
like move on yeah
trying to tell you i like my old videos
i made some videos on it
um it was just me like going 1v1 and i
was i was sitting in the middle because
i would never lose so i'm sitting there
like
who's next
that was fun times
okay i hear what you're saying that
sounds great and fire and stuff
but then at the same time that that dc
universe
game came out whatever i was playing
world of warcraft
oh yeah okay i feel you yeah so you see
see now and see the difference
so so i'm like i can't do this
i can't do this but king but king
there's an age gap you know
i was still oh yeah i feel that yo you
definitely tell the truth
yeah when that when that was out then
you know uh the younger squad started
gravitating towards that yeah and i'm
still
trying to do potions and and getting
some exactly
that i didn't level up to that until i
started playing um
that league of legends that uh the world
of warcraft i have way too much of an
addicting personality to get nowhere
near those games yeah
once i see king and saul getting into
that and i just like they really got
relationships in the world and i'm like
yeah no stop
stop messing with me for one day and he
entertained me
for one day and that was so beautiful
because you know when you take your
friend around
come over here and check this out and go
look over here because we got stuff over
here we got
shops and stuff and you know he's like
yeah he took a paddling i remember i'm
never gonna forget
the the i said who you made me i made a
bad thing all right so he goes over
there and he does this stuff
and then you know so i was like you
could tell you know he's not into it i'm
really like
all right so we can go over here and
craft some stuff and then we got to farm
this stuff here so you can farm and
he was like
he's like see you later brother
like i said transition out and then
obviously to the current generation
actually i mean you know xbox one
playstation 4.
yeah yeah exactly so you know obviously
xbox um when it was so successful to 360
at that time i mean i built a
built a computer actually during the
xbox one um
early early years just to play final
fantasy 14. i was the original
um final fantasy 14 um og when the game
was straight trash
before they rebooted it before they
rebooted it man i was i was
one of one of the founders man i had had
to live through that
final fantasy is the only game i've ever
seen to have lore
of their game blowing up and having
another one start
that's good they had to man it was such
a disappointment because like i said
with 11 for those who play final fantasy
11 you understand where i'm coming from
that game was so like so deep for those
like it was like the war crowd
or wild crowd and then the 11th crowd
okay yeah
so it was like between that i tried
world of warcraft it wasn't for me
i went to went to final fantasy 11
because you know the story is dope you
know how final fantasy do
yeah and then when it went to 14 figure
like it'd be a transition it was so bad
but i'm so you know
shout out to them for rebooting it yeah
you know i mean the guy did so well that
obviously he's he's making
16. so yeah so you see what i'm be
talking about but yeah so the xbox
first game on there was rise man my game
oh man the fastest that's like the best
900p game you've ever seen
facts
it still holds up i'm i'm mad as hell i
was like y'all supposed to use this
engine
to the whales yeah what the hell is
going on here i said playstation do it
tremendous gaming history sir a lot of
variety
diversity i like i play a five different
games man play a lot of different games
and then
how to get the playstation uh full and
got a war and all that came out it was a
rap
boy but like yeah exactly yeah i mean
that was hot fire but um and then like
this like this generation starting
the first time that i'm not gonna get an
expo i'm trying to get a playstation
first
for the first time ever and that's
mainly because you know that's mainly
because of the pc master race you know
poor choices
it's all love though because my mom pc
and i play all my xbox games you know
you know silly to phil spencer you know
he said it's good you know yeah you know
game passes on pc too baby
no no no no no no no no no no disrespect
no console no nothing they have it on
their phone so i
absolutely salute you but then when you
was like well i'll get this over that i
was like
it's not over that it's not over but i'm
still i'm still going to get xbox series
s
down the road because okay frames and
all that i'm not
the thing i'm always going to have xbox
console that's just perfect that's in my
blood baby
but yeah for me like i already have a pc
and i'm trying to make that
my my main i mean it's my favorite
box on pc did you were you able to
obtain the 3080 you know what the flex
f6 yeah
i did not yet i did not yet that's
that's what i said everything
i'm about to oh thirty-nine that's what
i'm going up baby you're doing 30 90.
man yeah i'm trying to get i'm trying to
get that man but like i said every night
i look i look at
look at my clothes though big now being
talk to you
to the big navio you ain't seen
whatever they call it man you know what
i mean
the first pc during right roughly when
the xbox one launched and guess i had a
head
i had i had an amd system oh and i
wasn't impressed you know what i mean
i can't do that and into my second build
i went i went you know nvidia and intel
okay so now now see now i'm gonna merge
them you know that means something
happening the video and then
hey listen right now because i got uh
i got nvidia my
but look man tremendous history love
what i'm hearing
but we got to get into like i said you
jumping into youtube content creation
like you know basically what kind of
spark that let's say you know what i
want to jump in i want to do some
content creation
all right so it's kind of kind of like a
two-part um first i
oh i've always watched like y'all in the
beginning when y'all had like 30 subs
that was in there
from you know from time you know i was
like yo these guys are legit man i love
watching y'all
and watch all the other guys at the time
was heavy in the xbox like i said in the
beginning
and i would always argue i would always
argue on the computer but i'm like man i
don't agree with that
like i'll agree with you i'll be doing
like man you ain't you
yeah i mean i'm like nah bruh yeah
there's too much cap and i'm gonna argue
and i'm realizing
i'm arguing by myself they can't hear me
man i could type so much but you know
first
it'll
i don't see none of that oh man
he put a program in code black
everything that's in white man
you know so party amongst yourselves
we're in vip up today
how you doing down there yeah so
yeah so that was one part of it and then
like i'm on the facebook group with
what my guy jubie senses in the chat oh
salute
shout out to him shout out to kofi so
it's us three yeah
and then um
japanese speaker yes sir oh
yeah exactly yeah maybe speaking that
playstation stuff man i gotta give him
his own segment man
in fact oh yeah so we was on like i said
i know these guys like in real life
i said i'd love to have him on bring him
over here
listen to this yeah man yo hit him up
he's a good dude absolutely i've heard
about it shout out to brad for the chat
right now
great to see fc hashtag dmv gaming no
doubt to our super chat yeah he was
doing i think
no doubt so continue sir so yeah so
you're speaking of course
yeah because all right back then yeah
like you said you know you know i i tend
to put the black gloves on so it's on
facebook these
facebook group called laid back gamers
right um with uh
like cool cats i went to school with
college with you know and then obviously
they went from 360
to to playstation straight away i was
always talking talking you know saucy
you know i'm like listen
and then it's like blah blah blah blah
you know me me and my god you based
on tag team it was just me and him going
against all these dudes
you're talking about you know but but
the exclusives are like bro you don't
play any of these games when you did
play me in halo you got washed you know
that i mean
stuff like that
you told my pure tribalism okay
talking all the sauce but y'all still
trashing games it was it was like that
and then kofi was in there you know we
were barking back and forth and then i'm
like listen i'm like
we're doing this for free we should be
able to do this on youtube or something
because like
the heat in the conversation you have
outside of just talking trash is
actually pretty good because i listen to
other people's podcasts
i'm like let's do something a little bit
different yeah and then they was like
yeah yeah let's do it let's do it
i'm like what's up yeah y'all gonna make
it no
i guess it's up to me that's when that's
when i started because there's always
one of those like yeah that's a good
idea until somebody you know until
someone actually
absolutely does it facts yeah so that's
why i was like i'll create it
you know i mean it's like hey i got it
now you ain't got no excuse come through
no
yeah i was uh i was on one of his
episodes a couple months ago
and creative coffee wasn't there like
midway through
he's like yeah kofi needs to be on every
episode he keeps being telling us
because because because my boy fc man he
was going crazy in that
[ __ ] yeah i had my moments
and i had my moments it happened
man you forget you forget but that was
over that was a lively show man look i
don't try to trigger me on my show man
but yeah so that's that's how it started
man the vitamin g gaming podcast
yes for those who don't know it's it's a
collection of gamers from all different
type of backgrounds you usually have a
preference to
a certain system so your voice will be
heard whether it be nintendo
whether it be playstation whether it be
pc
we're there man that's that's what it is
yes man so shout out to my guide like i
said you bae sensei
uh creative underscore kofi yes my guy
feral bazaar my god omar you named me a
hardcore pony for the pony nation who
know him
yeah you know who omar yeah i know yo
listen i had fun when i was on that show
yo shout out to my guy from again uh so
omar's from the netherlands and then my
other guy from uk
shout out to dante crisis it's the
united nations of gaming over there
man i like this that's what's up
that's right every flag is represented i
gotta shout you out because um
like i said i'm seeing the grind loving
you putting the work in i love that you
entertain healthy debate from all
consoles you just keep it skewed one
side
and then um oh shout out to the to come
and soul music i gotta i gotta plug you
with that
yes that left outside beat
that's whole body karate i like that
yeah i got i got i gotta hit up my guy
you already know man nyt
just like music man oh yeah actually you
know what i got that's another thing too
i forgot yeah i got plug he's actually
one of the ones that was pushing for me
to start a show
because my very first um scene on
youtube when i was trying look i was
trying to figure out how am i going to
start a podcast
from out of nowhere um i was like let me
let me see if i could get on some stuff
and then like one of my first shows was
with uh my guy uh
kell yeah he had a thing where it was
like
uh it was short-lived but it was like a
debate series right he's like
playstation guy for his xbox guy blah
blah blah it was 1v1 and then my very
first one was the was talking about the
xbox controller versus the playstation
controller
so it was me k mega k mega was like the
xbox coach
uh j dub he said the coach that's what
it was
fighters yeah
i forgot the other guy's name 1v1 and
then obviously you already know what
happened he got washed
up so that and it started from there and
my guy uh
like my team music hit me i was like man
you should yeah for real man make that
youtube dude
and ever since then man me and him man
it's an nfl and a fellow sailor you know
let me see
my [ __ ] mate uh so and he's like yo
let's do it and then i hit him up and
he's like man i'm trying to
trying to get something a little bit
different let's try to do this intro man
and so i got we got the the
the waiting the coming soon music it was
from ahead so nyt
nyt music and his cousin kinoflex which
i got him on the show
um a couple times he's the one who
actually created it and then i also
i don't know if you heard the actual
intro oh i forgot that i heard it
because you got the yes
right and then whatever spitting on the
intro is going crazy same dude
yeah that's crazy you know fletcher
graphics guy who created the whole
um the cinematography and all that so
salute to grab this guy salute to kino
flex salute to
nyt music that's my news man i love what
you're doing i love holla
even like the little bit of this stuff
kind of like goes with the beat
even with the bass parts and
salute to you i love what you're doing
very unique spin and
it's dope man keep grinding brother i'm
loving energy
hey we got you we got you out of youtube
you know what to say
we pulled you up man we got something i
gotta get my boy gotta make the call
yeah cause he
he's talking about you know king good
looking out you know
i was like first i don't give any
suggestions to kyle
only one suggestion i gave a cop and it
was my uh boy dolph castle
uh that's stony and then that's the only
person well him and lemon
um yeah those are the only two people
that i pushed for actively
but then you know what it is cog has a
schedule
yeah right cog is really working i don't
think he ever gets enough credit
for booking these dudes and doing all
the hard work and follow-up and talking
and everything and building yeah listen
like i said i'm out of that process
all i do is show up play some music all
right that's all i do
all right and and then i do my king of
the statues okay
so when y'all hit me like yo talk no
no no no no no
they do that stuff and it's a very
intricate thing
because he has to place people so yeah
every week i'm trying to figure out
who's next that's all
and my boy fc is on fantastic i had to
get fc man he's been doing it for a
while a lot like i said i love the
energy
and i love like i said just bring it in
we're going to get into the tops of
stuff with philips now but just bringing
in healthy debate
from different avenues different aspects
not just
one-sided all the time and it takes
open-mindedness to do that so that's why
i respect you
for what you're doing out here man so
keep the ground up but you know what
time
it is it's that time for that top five
right now
so we got to put some pressure on you
right quick top
five that are alive alive you know where
it stems from you know so you know
my top five games of all time four
franchises if you want to if you don't
want to do a specific franchises
okay all right well one one of them i
have to be my one probably the number
one or maybe
up there and when it comes to rpgs it's
golden side
that that is like i spent a lot of hours
solving a lot of hours and going inside
uh the next one
we got what we got i don't think trying
to think chrono trigger
is going to invite you on the last word
automatically
i know you hate destiny but he will
invite you just off of that choice alone
yeah i don't hate destiny
i mean yeah you know that's the trash
but listen it's that game pass bro
i was heavy in destiny 1. it's just i
don't know i don't know i don't know if
i was still hurt because of bungie left
or i don't know what it is
and it wasn't it wasn't what it was but
people thought it was going to be it
would be good
i could exactly exactly so we got we got
we got the sun joint
you know what i'm saying and dessert we
got we got number two what was that too
number two was uh chrono trigger chrono
trigger right right so now we got three
more
number three would be in no order in
order number
for number three though it would have to
be the halo series big time halo guy
uh ain't nothing like his first uniform
console guys
firstly that was one of those that
brought that multiplayer competitiveness
um and and the in the controls the first
person controls into
into the mainstream so solution to them
mlg all that
you know what you know about that oh
that's the noises of it yes
yeah man that's that's what it was
man uh you know halo killer spawn off of
that you know kill zone r.i.p you know
stuff like that
absolutely all right so
my other two two more two more two more
mass perfect mass effect that's right
yeah
master fact i gotta come back with that
and last but not least and
also r.i.p man spin or so oh
yo i don't think so man i think we
playing with our emotions but that's
that's r.i.p man it's r.i.p
no i don't think so i don't think it's
dead stick saying
you got one more run in them you can't
keep teasing them like that and
other things and not have something in
the works they
they are trying to bring it back in a
manner that
is felt when metal gear first came back
it was felt it changed the way it moved
so that's what they're trying to do
they're trying to get to that that space
where they can
leap like right now i'm playing resonate
evil 2 right
and i'm like oh my god i remember
playing it before
right but now it dropped it's felt so
they can springboard
and get more games out and flush games
out so
i think it's about springboarding and
they have to hit right for us
dessert talk about it yeah yeah yeah so
and like i said man i
i tend to just do a little bit different
when it comes to playing games like i
play with my brothers and i'll be like
know what i'll buy
a random game or something different
like what no i need you i need you back
halo 2. i'm like
nah man i mean i'm already the king of
that
nah i know joe goes top hundred in the
nation
so for those who don't know they had
like the different levels i was a 46
50 and then that's the that's the thing
that's the comment i had the comment
and then they started cheating man i'm
like listen man i'm
i can't i can't beat the cheaters man
but i wasn't 46 in team slayer
top hundred in the nation wow
you used to play uh agent versus um yes
that's what it was merc says yo chaos
theory baby
spy versus mercs that oh man that was a
whole different thing
and i like to talk trash so if i'm a spy
i gotta gotta be you know
ticklish yeah
i'm about to tell you so i'm over here
like this guy trying to find me i come
up to him
god got him in that headlock talking
about he's like oh you oh is that that
body the ex body spray yo you smelling
good
they'll be saying stuff back to me it
could be fun don't matter i'm over there
saucy baby
yes that was one of the coolest features
man i forgot about that
they never should have removed that yeah
they definitely should man
that's the best part absolutely you know
strong list and i think you already said
it but i need you to repeat it your
favorite console
of all time favorite console is the sega
dreamcast baby
that's mine that's my cosplay man it's
wow so a lot of things first
tell them what yeah oh man sonic
adventures when that thing hit
you know when it was 3d oh man that was
fire
for those who don't know nfl nfl 2k
yeah yo nba 2k with monster and iris
oh factual yeah for the first time i was
like
what is this yeah and then you have the
b you had the controller which the xbox
copied from
you know the best controller copied it
from somewhere and it was the dreamcast
and they had the vmus
yes video memory units when you would
play like uh 2k you could put you could
see the plays from the actual vmu rather
than on the screen
there ain't no screen watching yeah yeah
they mean so that was fire
i'm trying to think and then one of my
uh it didn't make my top games of all
time but one of the top rpgs that i love
skies of arcadia man yes oh man
you know there's still five new
dreamcast games right uh yeah
in new york they have a store called
video games in new york that they
recently got into publishing they've
done a couple of switch games
and they've been doing for a while
dreamcast games they have a new racing
game
there's a fighting game i'm not saying
they're the greatest games ever but the
new game
dreamcast wow man dreamcast definitely
yeah i'm sorry have seen you
i'll tell you and a lot of games that
came over oh my how did i forget
what's up shin moon man oh lord split
move one
revolution revolution it was that's what
i'm saying a lot of firsts it just did
something different
i love this and for those who don't know
man bizarre creations man project got
them racing
yes kudos kudos man
you know about that did you play the
first you played metropolis street racer
first
i played that too yeah that's what i'm
saying man yeah and then like what
people don't realize too like
dreamcast for his time graphically man
yeah that's so crazy i remember the soul
calibur port was amazing
i remember games like crazy taxi looking
phenomenal okay got that
um like it was great like you said the
sports games you had moss with the the
nfl the birth of the nfl the 2k series
right it was visual single greatest
launch
it had 18 games that you couldn't play
anyplace else
and that's the only console that i
purchased
and i purchased all 18
launch games crazy yes insane
it was you know without without shimmu
i'm a huge fan of white the samurai
and uh without shimmy i'm pretty sure
that game wouldn't exist
we could we could make the argument like
what's it the acoustic series right that
they birthed
that kind of yeah the great dudes
the ability to dare to be different yes
because
that when when shaman was coming first
of all we saw the graphics we couldn't
believe it
that was one and then the fact that you
know we
we are all children of uh channel five
right so yeah karate fix shaw brothers
run me shaw
shaw brothers yes so
when when we're able to get into that
world
and and run around and do mundane things
like
using a crane or talking to a little
girl to find her cat
have you seen a sailor that's fantastic
yeah
the fact that to me was so revolutionary
is you go into shops and they'll have an
arcade in the game where you can play
you know out run or hang on and all this
i thought that was
like like how is this happening it's
crazy
grab that super chat because he said
he's still relevant right now exactly
yeah power stone one and two for michael
skew junior two
super chat power stone one and two fire
yeah yeah we're getting
apparently in the leak we're getting a
power stone remake there is
there's a little bit of a uh a game pass
update that just happened on twitter
what we got it says i'll read the email
real quick it's not too long he says i
want to start by saying great work last
month waiting announcements i could
barely keep
track ea play coming to console cloud
computing beta
blottable in the xbox series x and then
here's where it is
but guess what we're not slowing down
for december ea
plays coming to pc and we have a ton of
games slated on top of that we've even
included
you know how they like to redact stuff
on the emos which our fans won't stop
mentioning that's why i sent you that
gif with the sinister red light
that's controlled
because remember when phil slipped up
i'm playing it said it early
remember yeah yeah and remember after it
didn't happen in like two weeks people
saying he was lying and they said he was
like cause he knew he had the paperwork
they came out and they were like i mean
remedy came out i was like nah
cause he snitched he wasn't supposed to
talk to her i told dude
i'm not buying it listen i know
this is one thing that you fearless
leader
this is one thing you know he wants
everything in there
he wants it to be everything in there so
for when y'all running out and buying
all these games early and just being all
willy-nilly with you guys
y'all obviously i do want to state that
it is redacted literally that is the
only game i could think of
that people make fun of that red
sinister like
and everyone in the comments section to
say it controlled so
no no
whoa yeah going all day man dreamcast
man except for the baseball games they
were the worst
oh yeah that wasn't even my lane
football basketball we was good that was
real good he was good on saturday right
i was good on
genesis and saturn there for me i
remember when they switched over and
sovereign was like oh hell no
but then that playstation came out with
a baseball oh
you know what i'm saying so we got to do
this poll though the uh oh get the
best star finance source off that's not
the finest with two dollars super chat
marvel vs capcom two the goat of all
time yes yes hello
so yeah man the winner of our three-way
iop
poll from last week let's get started
with the questions first how about that
um
with early comparisons of third-party
multi-plats such as assassin's creed
valhalla
and turf 5. this league performing
better on the playstation 5 to the
series x how concerned are you with the
perceived power advantage the series x
is supposed to have
the winner of the three-way ilp pole at
a whopping
71 percent was not concerned
most devs didn't receive the gdk until
june of this year
group coming in at second at 17
of the vote very concerned playstation 5
may prove to be the easier next-gen
console to develop for
or in last place at 11 of the vote stop
damage controlling
when your tcl don't even got vrr for the
st terran anyway
shout out to the lord who participated
last week folk
lord king uh they seem to be on your
side as far as the um
waiting on the gdk's and stuff like that
well because you know facts is facts and
truth is true i've already told y'all
how xbox is just
daddy we know for a fact that you know
this is straight brute force this is
see this is this is the fear of dudes
they are
juggling they are
overclocking they are boosting
in no part of the xbox resume do you
hear boosting overclocking and juggling
so all of this is just straight off the
rip now they say yo
when we start the workout workout
so it's it's nice that they're keeping
pace or
they they're doing something good in one
little area and then come a patch and
then they fall back to the wayside
so again dudes you know
the beast is coming you can hear the
footsteps
your heart beats oh like sasquatch oh
thundering down
you know what it is fear
you can smell it it's palpable
and all i see is fear in my timeline
because it hit me with yo king but it's
outperforming you don't got a tv to see
it
stop what happened you know so
1080i what do you mean exactly let's
look at
where they are performing and
outperforming the playstation
that's in stuff that's tangible that you
can see
you know so what really matters does
if a tree falls in front of you and you
see it all the falls in the forest that
you never heard
you never heard that tree over there but
when that tree falls in front of your
house you saw that
so microsoft is doing it in your face
playstation is doing it in the bushes
where you can never
find it i can't move it
this man is in his bag
anyway so let's get right into it man we
got these topics to get into but um yeah
phil dominus man he was out there huge
huge huge verge interview
hopefully uh some of you guys saw there
so you know huge interview out there
with the verge he spoke
on a lot of stuff man i know tribalism
was in there ex
um game pass model leadership stuff um
metrics a whole lot of stuff so i don't
know how much the realm got a chance to
catch or the excerpts but i want to
bring it to
lord fc man just your overall thoughts
of the interview whatever if you did
catch it
and what some of your takeaways on this
i mean
phil speaking the truth i know he gets a
lot of slack but what he says i mean
is is he wrong not in my opinion no
when it comes to a lot of factors i mean
i just want to hit on the stuff that i
took away
that i uh when he was talking about how
uh you know it's kind of like the
transition between
the how it is the old school way
and going into what it will be in the
future you know what i mean
like that part i feel like is
understated that
we are already transitioning and i feel
like even
even kova is kind of like helping move
into that alone when it comes to just
everything everything is
online you know we're shopping online
digital everything
so the fact that he's moving that he's
already kind of pioneering that
that wave to get into the game past the
future and getting
going away from the traditional model
it's you know it's it's it's
you know it's like well it's happening
so
for those who still doubt it as well to
me um oh the point
so i i got like i said man phil phil for
me and i made videos on this that he
he literally saved xbox and there's a
reason why he's in the position that
he's in
homie came from the basement facts to to
being second and
you know second in charge man you got to
have got to have some
some some something about you for that
to even occur absolutely
absolutely and he's and he's heading in
the right direction for me so i mean
salute to phil man and then
i can't wait for these these xbox um
games because i would be able to play it
on pc
king yeah that i'm gonna enjoy
i'm not bothering you and shaming you
over there because he made it possible
for everybody to game wherever they're
comfortable
and that's mainly what he was talking
about in his interview
you know um the ability to do this and
and
still feel comfortable you sit at your
pc and you game
this is something that you're used to
doing something that you have
always done and now the ability to
to partake in game pass on your pc
is a utopia for you beautiful i've
always gamed in my
living room i've all that has i really
very rarely gamed in my bedroom so
when game pass is in the living room i'm
great i won't
never hit my pc i don't care what i got
in my pc i don't care if i got
30 90s i don't care i won't play on it
so if the ability to do so
and wherever you're comfortable at if
you're comfortable on your phone you can
do this
right so it's the ability to be flexible
that i took
most from this verge but when y'all get
to certain parts i'll
chime in no doubt no doubt but yeah but
i i agree i see definitely some good
solid points there especially what you
said you know him charting his journey
right
from yeah it's crazy yeah like he was
talking about the bill gates error
billy g you know and the thing is like
he took a little bit from everybody you
know i mean like when bill gates was
there you know it was
it was his baby pet project and all that
and then
obviously the next leadership how he
took the more business approach from it
and he talked about how yeah obama how
you went
overseas got out of redmond and yeah had
to experience that like what do you say
like
you know it's easy to um oh it's not
it's not verb like
quote for code but it's easy to like try
to understand how microsoft is in
redmond in that bubble but
you have to understand how xbox is to
other people that's not from that area
so like in europe and overseas
you get a better understanding and i
feel like that experiences that he that
he's had
and with different leadership um
involved every time you had a new
leadership involved
you take away and learn from that's a
smart that's a smart thing man like like
he's a silent assassin like king be
saying
down for this talk yeah you know i agree
i agree i i
definitely caught that vibe you know
learning from um you know different eras
and stuff like that and then even from
him with the uh
i believe you know with game creation
and stuff like that you know he had
tremendous experience
let's get to attic i don't know how much
you caught of uh phil dominus's
interview with the verge and if you did
uh any takeaways or anything that stood
out to you
i think it was interesting that um one
thing
is i i don't like when a lot of people
interview phil right now because i feel
like they do nothing but like
try to reward questions to get the
bethesda answer
it's just like they ask one thing and he
he like loki's like i can't answer that
then like five minutes later they've
reworded that question to try to ask
again
yeah because they want to know you know
just the stupid answer
uh did you pay seven billion to have
your games on playstation five hell to
the no idea
so i know right now you guys are holding
out hope beyond hope
but i'm gonna tell you where was that
same energy for nintendo when y'all took
final fantasy
where was that same energy every time
y'all took a a game and made it
a console staple that didn't reach
nobody else
we don't even have to go that far sony
literally just bought
exclusives like they brought go uh those
two games from bethesda that's why
they bought final fantasy 16 they bought
all pretty much the entire final fantasy
vii remake franchise like
sony's doing this in in a big way if
people just act like microsoft
it's fine when they do it you know the
there's no
outcry when they when they say uh you
know final fantasy is over here
you know and it's okay it's it's
business it's war
right it's war
so when bethesda doesn't show up it's
war and just keep that same energy
now you can play the little online games
that we give you because we want
all of your money okay
and we want you to purchase loot boxes
and be in the ecosystem and have fun
corporate king but you will not partake
in the next doom
you will not partake in anything that is
solely a triple a title you will watch
from afar
when you want to join you can
it is war so so just out of curiosity
because you know obviously
on both sides what would you say to the
people that say
but king in that last interview that
microsoft executive said it's going to
play first on
xbox on xbox and play better on xbox
what are you going to say to them
individuals that's the online games he's
talking about
okay okay you know so if if you want to
play uh
skyrim online
we will have it everywhere it would be
all over the place
for you you can touch you can partake
you will pay the 69.95 to join
where
you would buy loot boxes and crates and
season passes
where we will get her free king
you will partake but when you see
starcraft or whatever star system
whatever
that game is you will not partake
from a fall okay so that's what it means
by choice was it uh
choice basis what is it game by choice
basically listen
he's doing corporate speaking right now
right and then i don't
you know what he he wants to do he wants
it to be a system shot when it drops and
it don't drop for you
i mean i i shake i have to
you know i went back and i looked yeah i
think i've said this in other podcasts
before
like i looked because i remember it was
a big you know
is hell blade 2 going to be an exclusive
that's how it to
people people to this day even say it's
going to be everywhere
but if you look and you you know you
advance search tweet and i don't
remember any articles really
microsoft never formally came out and
said this game
is going to be on anything they didn't
even people asked they never commented
on it and then when the actual
uh you know trailer shows up obviously
we know that's an exclusive and
yeah and i get it people say but attic
they didn't spend 7.5 billion dollars on
those
you know they didn't but they let's be
real here that that was still
billions of dollars they did to buy all
those studios
it wasn't maybe 7.5 but it was at least
two
so your logic makes no sense because
they've been doing this and this is the
way they've been carrying out
this is the way all right
i don't like the messy language around
it you know that if you're not going to
be clear just shut up
because all he did was well they do shut
up but they get
what it is is they keep going on these
these uh these interviews where that's
what i mean like
about it he tried to get any type of
language about it
no it is like when when you know you and
your relationship is over with your girl
right and you keep asking her are you
good and she's like yeah honey don't
worry about it
yeah honey don't worry about it and then
you found out that i was broke up
you find out oh wait wait wait what's
going on
you know it's done you know you asking
for confirmation so
you can move on
move on so you got you get served with
the papers let's just go
on the playstation dudes move on
either run out and buy us right now see
the this is
they got a box for them though
it's a violent but this is actually what
users you know what i mean
this is exactly can't run 120 but it's a
60 at least
it is for them it's for them but he said
you know what listen i understand y'all
guys in a particular right now we spend
seven
you know what we did we got the most
powerful box but
you know hey look buy this for 300 and
you could partake too
or put game pass on your phone or if you
got pc
join us because you will have to join us
to get this stuff so shout out to
jellybeans he said you like an anime
villain
you know what it is we every
world doesn't dude every xbox dude
had to hear sony playstation nation
talking all this crap and smack and
y'all was running around willy-nilly
purchasing stuff and doing things
and y'all was like well microsoft got
all this money they should be doing
now yeah they are woke
oh my god why did y'all poke that bear
now you're getting mauled
oh my god you know when y'all get eaten
whole
uh because when you get to my part it's
gonna have some questions for your
when it comes down to it it's like you
know
what i what i really thought was
interesting is
is the fact that this man phil
phil dominus maximus spencer aurelius oh
i forgot to be real
correct so he the the
the individual that was interviewing him
i can't remember his name but um
he kept trying to get him to allude to
you know
concerts going to be in relevant right
he kept multiple times he tried to
he's like look he's like and what with
right so i mean look at the way
technology's going you wouldn't make it
see
but phil never even remotely gave him
that slack he's like
but you know we're gonna have an app and
he's like well i don't necessarily think
that he's like
right now i find myself buying more
hardware for audio
by better tvs to play hardware he's like
and he was the loot he's like look i
don't think the console is going to go
anywhere
it's just you're going to always have
that hardware to complement
everything else in your room it's like
you know a lot of people have with uh
you know digital media people prefer
physical media because you can get a
better quality experience
with the blu-ray in the 4k ultra
blu-rays
in your you know your your actual
hardware
you get a better fidelity regardless
just because you have that disc in
general
right yeah and i thought that was
interesting that you know
because normally they've been a little
when
when when that thing that happened to
sovereign happens and if he had a disc
uh xbox i mean playstation and you know
he had his disc
he would be able to throw it in but now
he has to show sony
that you know hey um i did own these
games
and then christopher hart says something
about restoring your licenses i did that
and it was not there wow and it was just
stole
money from him they literally stole two
games from me
air force ones went inside his
playstation 5
and they pocket and listen if y'all
trying to figure out how they
subsidizing this
there's the gpus and that all that big
heatsink
by stealing your games
yes sir you know you know what they're
going to do there
so it's going to hit the like well sir
in our records it says you never bought
it and they're going to be like smiling
on the other side of the phone
but what we'll do is we'll give you ten
percent of uh a ten percent off your
next game
wow yeah it's a repurchase yeah yeah
that part is a little wild i mean just
going to show you that again
when you know you hear terms like smart
delivery a lot of stuff is just not
corporate speed a lot of stuff is just
not buzz words because
again i had no issue you know with the
ecosystem as far as saving on you know
on xbox and
moving around from platform to platform
everything went to the cloud and then
came down to the system yeah
it's ridiculous how how that whole
thing's handled and i was talking to
cognito and i was like look i get it
i personally do not agree with sony
hiding
the the cloud compute the cloud saves
behind
a subscription service uh but you know i
guess people don't want to ever talk
about that like
they're literally holding you rants and
be like we ain't gonna let you into the
vault
until you give us money at the door yeah
it is just like you know how many people
just assume things work the way it
should in 2020
that they could just buy the next
consoles and it's going to come with
them
like i don't even know if i'm going to
play persona 5 again i'll have to start
that game over for the third time
and i'm sitting here looking up like i
don't even know if it's worth it i'm
looking at my groceries you see my
platinum
and all the stuff i do and i can't do
new game plus right now
i'm tight
i didn't see them being vocal about that
i didn't see them making tweets
so i didn't see them making a youtube
video like
you know one thing i'll give microsoft
don't have to do this because their
stuff's naturally
but if microsoft did have to do
something like this they would have been
a youtube video or something that's like
that's showing you the process at least
right wait wait wait
you said naturally microsoft been
cutting a teeth
for years building to this moment
where the other dudes just took it for
granted that their fan base will
accept every and anything that they do
that double download process is stupid
and it was stupid in the playstation
that's why i didn't game over there
because why should i have to download
and then i have to install it
then copy and copy that's what i thought
i thought it's a service i paid for
again yes is it my fault for not doing
due diligence and looking into the
research and extra steps yes
but like king is saying like why why
your competitor and everyone else is
doing this so why does it why is it not
an automatic
thing you do talk about it when you do
talk about it they don't say
the part about manually uploading to say
they don't say anything about that they
just say oh you have them available to
you now
right that's right christopher hart said
all my games were preserved but not
everybody restores licenses on consoles
as much as i do
just think about that sentence
christopher hart you have to click
another option in your settings to get
licensing back shout out to hearts a man
you're going to defend anything man if
you got to go run a marathon for
somebody he'll do it
i love this if you haven't even go get
cheesecake when he would do it
brother
as well
let's get us off man because a lot a lot
of points feel made
and um another thing i want to comment i
want to get you up you know is actual
the tribalism part you know and how he
felt very strongly
about this you know i mean so just
overall what should it take for the the
phil interview
so oh let me get these two first king
spin fire from squirrely dan two dollar
super chat thank you sir
then we have restored hades with the
hold on jump me five dollar super chat i
think microsoft means
by play first on xbox is better on xbox
i believe they're talking about games
coming out first on xbox and later to bc
uh i don't know i don't see them
dropping games day and date on pc as
well
i don't see that um because you want to
you want that zeitgeist right you want
everybody to be
as many people on as possible right dave
um so what did i feel about generally a
lot of things you guys mentioned
were very interesting to me when he
talked about the succession of of of
leadership
at microsoft and how he saw different
things in each of them if you look at
phil is a very observant type of person
he is very when you compare him to the
other heads of xbox
he's the quiet one that's sort of in the
cut he observes
he he takes notes and he reacts and then
i think
over the years that has formulated his
sort of management style where he is
very
like i imagine behind closed doors that
phil is very to the point like we got to
get this done
but he knows how to play the business
side of it and he knows how to play
the the side where you're talking to the
consumer right and in addition to him
being a gamer that gives him a certain
level of clout with the people
purchasing their product that
you don't get from a jim ryan or
something a suit per se right he's obama
like
he is very yeah he's very much i'm in
this with you guys right and
that comes across so i think the fact
that he saw the way that bill gates was
with bill is very much
you know he bill's starting this
business but at the same time he's very
much a tech guy and he cares very much
about
the product and how it functions right
so you see that aspect and you see
balmer who is who is a marketing guy
he's a business guy he's like sells a
cell
right it's you you get that you get that
that sort of schooling and then when you
have satya who is
again the middle ground guy that he is
the guy who
is the tech guy but he also understands
the business of it
and he also has vision about where
microsoft needs to go in the future
it sort of to me formulated who phil is
as a manager
as a leader um that's very interesting
now when you talk about the uh the
tribalism
the fact that you know you've seen the
arguments like it's very easy for him to
say that he doesn't like it when they're
not
winning right say that right but at the
same time like dude we're here
and we talk about this every week to me
it's funny when you're a young kid
arguing about this stuff and you're in
the lunchroom and you're like this is
better is that that's cool i get that
cause that shows passion for the product
bro i'm 45 years old i'm not i'm not
about having an argument with anybody
like i don't i i don't it doesn't make
any sense to me to have that argument
with anybody
if you were my age and i understand
people's people the ability that people
have to purchase things or whatever is
different i
i get that but at the same time i don't
see you coming on to a platform talking
ill of some other machine that you
don't play or you have no interest in
but you're speaking up on it like like
you have this knowledge of it mm-hmm
don't do that like don't do that and at
the end of the day
i i take issue with the gamers that are
super selfish and don't understand that
it is their job especially in a world
where we have such access to social
media
and everybody's opinion is out there and
everybody's opinion has a platform
like you have to be you if you you have
to be cognizant of what the things you
say and do
do to the thing that you love and then
we have to be cognizant of that and if
you tearing down the other man you don't
want
trust me nobody wants to see nintendo go
anywhere nobody wants to see
xbox one you don't want that scenario to
happen it's funny you brought that up
because going to put my brother king
david on trial here we go
because phil david has said some very
powerful statement that is contradictory
to the things i've heard from the king
so
you
you got to click his his his picture on
the google hangouts we got to see
this i need to see this
you were the first person i thought
about this tribalism of statement
and he makes it oh man powerful comments
king and
you know in the past king you have been
known to say that you know you do not
care
if saudi goes into the bushes if they
are away
if they you you want them assimilating
you with all their games
these are things that the king has said
so according to phil he does not want
that he said
he does not need the competitor to die
and he's he said soldiers a partner over
here
so i give the floor how do you respond
to said leadership from philadelphia
let's continue sir
name full name phil davis max was uh now
really
yeah yeah phil dominus maximus really a
spencer sir yes yes yes
fearless leader is is it's like you're
saying
fear fearless leader
is always true in his words but i say
this to say
first first grab that super chat real
quick yes we got michael excuse me
if i lost my progress in 13 sentinels i
would have been hot
good to see iop brought the homie fc on
i see this forced him to finally get a
haircut oh my god
listen i had the best afro on youtube
yeah i mean that kobe froze
let's go good we're good all right all
right so
let's say you you know what i tell my
children
um when they go to school don't fight
right don't fight
but if you do i want to pick up the
winner
that means don't lose
don't lose the fight see what phil is
telling you is
you know king is about to do the
greatest
what phil is telling you is that you
know the toxic
nature of tribalism is something that
repulses him
yes when he sees an individual that
would say well i will never purchase an
xbox because i don't like the controller
or whatever the hell whatever for
whatever reason
now i don't subscribe to tribalism but i
subscribe
to the word and this is the word what's
the word
in everything you pick aside okay we've
been trained that way
as a child it's always been red or blue
you know republican or democrat or you
know
rice and beans or french fries or
whatever it's always been
a choice right so when you went to the
store
and i would question this with him right
he gave you so many options that he
takes away
a lot of those choices when you walk
into the store
but i can guarantee you when you walk in
the store you only have 500
he wants you to walk out with an xbox
he doesn't want you to walk out with a
playstation 5. right
so you said
that i've always called for sony demise
yes you suppose i i have the quote here
oh
i want them cognito has come to
i want them to perish yes yes you said
this i want them to perish
okay i want them to be exactly what they
re branded their self is
sony playstation studio but but i have
to interject
lord king oh phil dominance says phil
would love to have the last of us on
xbox
okay but his exact phil would love to
have ghost of sashima
produced by sony on xbox phil will love
to have every game uh that the place a
god of war
produced by sony running on an xbox all
right but
this is what he's not going to promote
but he said something else the fight
he ain't like he don't want you to talk
okay
listen listen he's not gonna promote the
fight okay he's not gonna promote
yo i want you to you know no no no no no
but if they so happen to trip and bump
their heads
he's putting on the face there he's oh
he this is pure corporate
corporate but at the same time he says
ready to bayonet
okay okay so that's how i have to
interpret this what you're saying say
this you know why i can say this
yes we've seen
a lot of individuals in different lights
right right now
this is he's really in control of the
ship
right he's not he's not running uh
xbox one that was made by somebody else
that was brought to the system by
somebody
he this is his launch yes this is him
this is this is the realest feel that
you're gonna get right
you you he has his boxes
and he made sure that he put his imprint
in that way so it's going to be copied
from here on out
other people will give you a powerful
box and a less powerful box
you know game pass his imprint
right series he's making his imprint
so at the same time he doesn't want to
be tripped up by stupid stuff
like tribalism and i really understand
it and get it
but that is to
slowly bring you in close oh you don't
want tribalism
you want and he also told you it ain't a
kumbaya thing either
right he didn't say that he told so
i'm not trying to hug you brother
i mean if if your enemy
tells you i don't want to talk bad to
you but i ain't trying to hug you
can i say something real quick i think
you know king's completely 100
i think phil mainly means when he's
making these statements that he's like
look
he's like i i think we can all succeed
but
he he's not talking about like like
giving sony handouts or anything like
that he's like look like
i want everyone to see and i want
everyone to do good but
you know he he said there it plain in
that interview he's like beside the
kumbaya thing
he's like i i do want us to do good too
the exact quote that no one's letting me
finish oh
he said as i've said before this is
not a two-may enter one may leave
scenario could you imagine if you're the
director of a movie and you wanted
another movie to be bad
so that people would you know maybe
directors do whatever then he goes on to
say
he says look we're at the businesses uh
we're the best trying to be the best we
inspired to be he said i can't
target microsoft and say hey the board
of microsoft our enemy is the sony
company we should go take them out
it's not even in our vocabulary to talk
about sony that way
they're a partner of ours frankly in a
lot of different places
yeah i'm excited okay can i inject yeah
yeah so i mean i i mean yo king salute
to him man
he knows how to you know [ __ ] died or
punches but
like like for me though what i
understand what phil is saying like yeah
you're right he is a partner but i see
it kind of like
if you look at the you know i'm not
saying we do that but like the drug game
right yeah like
you see a territory a map of the
territory xbox wants the whole map
and give a little bit of it to sony like
yeah they you know they're
they're paying us like i mean that def
loop time exclusive that's oh you're
doing boss talk you're doing boss talk
yeah
what i'm saying is like yeah i don't
want them to fail because that means my
revenue is going good
okay i see okay this is what this is i
want them to i want them to help me
okay you know you know like pay me you
know let's help each other out but the
whole time
i'm gonna buy the i'm gonna buy the
whole damn publisher
like if you listen to what king said
king doesn't want him doesn't want them
to have a box anymore right kingdom
thank you i want them to have a
microsoft don't do that
exactly you understand this there's a
revenue check that comes in every month
you just want them to be on the server
my
server my thing is the reason that
you know a lot of people want to have
like this narrative that like
microsoft they that they don't try to
compete with sony
all from that one comment that that's
that phil spencer made about you know he
doesn't
what she wasn't even talking about
calling so he's talking about cloud
computing but we won't go into that
it's like if it was truly they don't see
them as a competition that you know
they they're just trying to make money
hellblade 2 would be on playstation
all these every game would be on
playstation
but we that's not the case you know i
say this
they bought they bought those studios
and all those games
you know besides the bethesda games we
don't have a 100 clarification on that
yes we do
oh we still don't have 100 clearance
at the end of the day we at the end of
the day the games that they did buy
the games that we do know right they're
not on playstation
right not a fan it's just like you know
not everyone gotta be
like my my problem with the the
community
is people want that like windy social
media thing
like they want wendy's well you know
pete wendy's is well known for they for
they you know they smash talking on
twitter
like they always be doing it it's just
like phil spencer's just pretty much
saying yo
we can both prosper without me wishing
the other person exactly
it's like the tenant's a landlord
relationship
you know what that's exactly a nice crib
you got a nice crib but microsoft the
landlord
it boils down to where was all this
energy when microsoft was at death door
when you when when you guys were sitting
out here running around talking about
yeah they done
that's it this thing last bite they're
about to die they said they didn't go
forward then phil stepped up and said
hold on wait a second hold my bed
hold my bear let me show you what we do
when they only had three studios
actually and sony was out here killing
it with their first parties and stuff
like that phil said hold my bear
hold on one second i've been here since
day one i've started down here
factual so i'm working my way up you
think he's working his way
up to to what place second fiddle to who
he's not working his way up to play
second fiddle this is his
time i feel that now so
you guys sitting here wanting this
kumbaya you want him to stop he ain't
gonna stop till he break your neck
so all you guys didn't have an
attachment baby
what's funny is people people used to
say i i just want
i want microsoft to not act kumbaya too
like
well it's time now this is it this is
this is the beginning of the end
right so when i tell you guys i want
sony finish i want them
done i want that box don't to show up i
don't want no dude
i want sony to operate like sega this is
for the definition
this is what's saying this is for the
homies let me tell you something i
never forget
my payback you dudes killed off sega
and there wasn't no tears in the street
now when you're all on the ground
a formidable foe you're fighting a dude
that's cash
flush i don't care for your tears
i just want your game i don't care if
that box
ever shows up again but i want last of
us three on the xbox
i wanna go sushima 2 on the xbox i want
god of war and
xbox and i want you guys to have to pick
up that controller
and bend the damn knee like i had to
bend the knee
when sony killed sega so right now i
picked a real winner
a juggernaut and phil dominus maximus
really expensive is going to make this
happen and all let me tell you something
this is this and you guys better listen
to what i'm telling you
everything i told you came to pass
everything i told you
this generation playstation will not win
this generation oh
that's strong and i'm telling you
i'm telling you and and it all started
with those same questions y'all have in
your heart
going to be hello here with us
does not have these thoughts because
what will happen is king makes these
statements
and then all the rest of the iop lords
will get attributed to this that these
are the thoughts of
king please be clear that tribalism at
work
exactly that's what we need we need the
thoughts of king emotion
we need to thought to king like this is
clearly king we need a corporate king
and we need the thoughts of king
facts you talk about you talking about
disclaimer yes yeah okay so
yeah okay when when when they killed off
sega
yeah listen [ __ ] with you he said yo
you know what you may be onto something
because he used to love sega he ain't
like i went down
i feel like i didn't man i feel like
they're a publisher now right
they still alive right i mean listen i i
agree with that to a certain extent as
well but at the same time
you think it did kind of do sega in like
yeah
right now giving them a big box that's
over here what's up with all that big
heaps
and all that stuff this what didn't they
have liquid cooling what's going on
they don't tripped up and keep on baby
keep on that's all i'm saying
you're gonna trip up so much you're
gonna fall out the game
anyway before we before we carry on yes
here in about 30 minutes i'm gonna be uh
asking that question
and uh it's it's gonna be iop related so
you these members go at the
they're going to know guests that we've
had in the past
shout out to the 429 in the chat yo hit
that like button man a lot of fun today
man look i'll make it quick you guys hit
all the major points you know what i'm
saying you know
look you know at the end of the day i i
do think uh
phil is is alluding to certain behaviors
that have
happened here on this podcast on
occasion but for the most part
you know i just think he he's talking
about not on
you know basically having to to need
that to happen as far as like you said
big boss talk
partnership you know looking at these
relationships you know what i'm saying
yeah we might joke around but i honestly
truly don't think phil was talking about
any of like our personas on this podcast
like
i think he's talking about the hardcore
people the people
that are always in podcast talking smash
that's who he's right
how i take from it when i listen to phil
talk about the tribalism in that sense i
look at it as him saying like the people
who are going online
like king just never goes online to
provoke and initiate and go to act
somebody
and personal attacks people come to his
line
and then king defends itself but as far
as in general
i think that's where people take it a
little too far like once you're going
into a personal attack zone
and you're mad at someone else's
enjoyment of the opposite platform
that's what he's talking about that's
what is left right you you're on some
because now not only are you not just
happy with what you have
you have to go out your way to
disrespect someone for their other
enjoyment you know what i'm saying you
know i'm glad that you brought that part
up for a second
sorry to catch you go get it i'm glad
that you brought that up because on my
timeline
if you look at my stuff i don't anywhere
anybody
fast it's not i don't i do i don't need
to ask
people i don't i don't do it if i put
out something it's just whatever right
it's my thoughts for the second
and then i get a ton of
uh other side or playstation side or
whatever you want to call it
i get a ton of them on a xbox guy's
timeline
my question is why are you here why do i
reach your radar
if you never have any intentions of
purchasing the box partaking inside game
pass or whatever and you have so much
games and you're having so much fun
why is my little bit of words hurting
you in a manner
exactly and this is back to that
toxicity
that he's talking about with tribalism i
never
you never listen listen never i never
and i
never check for you dudes factual i
don't go on your page i don't care what
post you make
actual i don't care about anything that
you do
your line and that's the thing when you
as someone is initiating drama again
when we look at the digital foundry
stuff and
people jumping on this guy's line to be
mad because the
the side by side ain't go their way you
know what i'm saying that's what we're
talking about you know because
here's the thing y'all know i play
destiny i know i get clowns oh you still
playing that game six years
yeah i do not care exactly
and i'll be like yup hold on i'll be
like yup and nothing's stopping my
enjoyment
you know what i'm saying you know what
crazy about the whole destiny thing
called
you know it's like we will go at each
other over destiny
all the time like constantly me talking
about
an argument what wasn't are you it's a
disagreement of osiris like three or
four days ago yeah it's like
why do you think that people that don't
play destiny we care about what you have
to think about
if you're comfortable in your own skin
and your own purchase
no man is going to move you off your
square so that you emotional
you know i'm saying that's the problem
with these dudes it's just
not to me what phil's talking about when
these dudes take it
to this next level where they got to
attack somebody just because they like
something else like that's great
that's like i don't come from that and
the thing i last what i want to say and
i said this on games on daily like
king we from that era fc we from that
era
where it's like yo it wasn't cool to be
a gamer back in the day
like you was clown to be a gamer you
know what i'm saying
so when i look at dudes beefing each
other over games
y'all look crazy to me because at the
end of the day this is the unifier
this is what brings us together you know
i'm saying now i remember that era when
it wasn't cool now like you got
mad old people playing everybody's
playing celebrities celebrities playing
like it was not you'd be embarrassed to
go to the phone call the game started
do you remember like when you have a a a
a partner come over to your house
and you know they they doing whatever
like let's say they cook
cooking in the kitchen or whatever and
you pick up a controller and you play in
your game like you play games
yup when you're a child or something
like that when i was growing up
there was always two things that i was i
wasn't embarrassed by but it always took
more explanation when it comes to the
opposite sex
it was video games and playing yu-gi-oh
and with buddies people would be like i
remember i'll never forget i
i was talking to this chick and she's
like and i was like yeah i play you he's
like my little brother used to play that
that's like yeah your brother probably
sucked that's why you stopped playing i
did
what do y'all what do y'all know about
your mom you know i mean talking about
you you know you keep playing that
nintendo yeah the next box
everything nintendo you know you know
no you know what it is when my mother
would say that you're wasting all this
money on this
and then nothing you're sitting there
you're right in your brain
and i send her the podcast
bro and and and also the comic books
oh you're sitting here reading all these
comic books and all this and i send her
kos facts and you know what she said to
me
what she said i should have supported
you more
eggs bro let me say anything let me
bring it back
you already know mama carter yeah right
14 12 dudes the whole block everybody's
project come through coghouse
right yeah y'all making no i don't see
why y'all playing them gabe what's the
point yeah i can't do anything right
soon as now time going on you know
obviously people
have moved and stuff i showed her the
podcast
oh i remember soft i remember yeah they
used to come through
i remember oh look at this you see the
difference it's it's
the the the progression to what it's
become
and and now it's an appreciation you
know what i said
and then she see we give it up like yo
mama car y'all i know we was wild back
in the day
but you know what i'm saying you kept me
off the street you know what i'm saying
like you know like
it was i seen the tear in her eye like
she was like i should have supported you
boy
because you were doing something to keep
everybody
off the block and nothing can take
that's what i said when i look at this
clown garbage that's on
twitter with dudes fighting each other
real beefing over again
it's crazy you know
one thing that i have to really
appreciate and you know i don't like a
lot of the main mainstream games like
the minecraft
i don't mind minecraft i wouldn't use
that like the fortnites the call of
duties
like as much as these games have never
really resonated with me
these games is the reason why gaming is
popular
actually like without these games we
wouldn't be where we are now
whatever we we would have people like
like famous rappers playing fortnite
exactly and that's the and that's the
thing about phil and his message and
about where he sees the future of gaming
going that's very interesting to me
because
phil they they come out and they say
outright look we really want to reach
these whatever four billion gamers right
and it's and it's not hyperbole because
the thing is you've already seen
gaming elevated to a certain point you
don't want to see it go back to being
this niche thing
if you want in movies you want more
people to do it so
i i like that approach where he they're
being very direct about what they're
trying to do
to promote gaming and to put gaming in
more people's hands whereas
sony i feel is doing the same thing
but is playing on on them
being like the hardcore gamers console
where they're not changing the status
quo
and we know what you know real gamers
want you know
they they're playing on that in a way
that i feel
in the moment when you look at it moment
to moment you you're like yeah they're
still doing things the old way at the
same time when you hear jim ryan talking
about
oh um yeah we have some plans for ps now
we have making some adjustments some
pivots
being very disingenuous about the fact
that they are
found they to me their fault they follow
what microsoft is yeah they're just
they're just doing it at a slower rate
even though
the generation the whole generation you
said pinocchio if there was a hardcore
console they wouldn't have
games crosstalk you know i mean it's a
slower rate exactly and it's all the
everything is the tea leaves are there
right it's just to me it bothers me when
they're not
genuine about it right when when he
comes out
and he's he and he says like oh i'm
really i'm really surprised that people
are mad that miles morales is on ps4
what
what after what you're saying like come
on now we gotta do it
yeah we're not doing it but let me let
me write this because
powerful powerful topic definitely one
to get our bars off love what everybody
had to say
let's get this super chat there we go
move on let's get that song okay
we have hold on we got uh
one bad mother with the five dollar
super chat community needs to continue
to knock out tribalism like it's nate
robinson
on twitter
knocked out
thank you iop for setting the example by
celebrating people and creativity thank
you
sir you already know smitty smith with
the five dollar super chat
phil ain't playing second fiddle he is
the whole damn orchestra the book of
acts
then we have jonathan b with the five
dollar super chat king is really thanos
this is the equivalent thing half of the
universe has to be wiped out
it's inevitable it's for balance
inevitability here we have michael aka
best eyes finest with the five dollar
triple check
damn peter moore said he jumped into the
console fight because the dreamcast is
gone
so pretty much xbox is the true
successor from dreamcast uh yeah we've
always thought
about that yeah yeah that's why that's
that's why i'm here baby
then we got one away dragons the five
dollar super chat who just became the
biggest video game company
in the world with less consoles so yeah
again the metrics that for measuring
that stuff
just it's different now it just totally
is
um we have dan the man cunningham with
the five dollars i love that name
how the sega extract revenge from sony
by selling the microsoft the enemy of my
enemy is my friend
that's boss talk i already know which i
love the wise old gamer with two dollar
super chat did we have the tribalism
discussion yet yeah
yes we did
uh why the way dragons tv with the two
dollar super chat they're on twitter
of beefing with rabbit ears
factual they would even see them tvs in
these modes but look man
we gotta move on man so look we got that
timer
yeah this is king's topic i believe um a
little gpu
situation i believe that king wanted to
talk about so
before we get into this messiness
because this topic is about to be messy
uh let's just go ahead and do this
membership giveaway go for it
all right so this is the question and i
even thought about this question all
right in 2018
we had an e3 prediction show
there was one lord that was mad late for
the for the microsoft
conference who was it
for the microsoft prediction show there
was one lord that was late to the
podcast
who was it the first member to say it
you gotta have that green or that little
icon man you gotta have it
you you i will uh i will hit you up on
twitter
nope nope no he said nope nope
no it's not a lore it's like a lord
isn't a guest
the man who got them awards okay all
right
hit me up on twitter man hit me up on
twitter we got it
who got it yeah
you see when i start when i thought
about doing these i want to reward
people that's been
it's been worth it for a while you know
what i'm saying right exactly you got to
do it
and they say cp time
you got to prove to me that you the same
account and then i'll
we'll get you your code so yeah let's
get to this
yeah we got a game over brian with the
five dollar super chat
can we stop tribalism and king finally
acknowledge that tcl is a great tv
yeah listen let me tell you something
it's a great tv if you need a s
it's a great tv if you have a
playstation 5. it's a great tv if you
have a playstation 4.
it's a great tv if you don't want much
from your tv
that's it and i have no problem with
individuals that love tcl
um if listen
it's called tcl because it's the cheap
life oh i'm dead and
that that that's where you at with it so
if
if you like to pick your tvs up off the
floor and walk and put them in your
head that's for you like you like to
pick your tv up you walk in the store
your tv on the floor
and put it in the cart and you go out
that's how you want to do god bless you
have a good day
me personally they bring my tvs from the
back or they ship it
at the end of the day man king ever
since i got this samsung
i don't know what a tcl is i don't
exactly
look at you
let's think about it this way if you
walked inside a restaurant and your meal
was on the floor you had to pick it up
and go
would you eat that meal no you won't
oh dude we gonna get a cease and desist
ucl hit us up with that spawn
it's gonna be a season sponsor and the
funny thing is if the lord's gotta
sponsor tco
after all is moving i honestly feel like
if tcl hit us up
and we want the sponsors he's like you
have to get that product up before you
show up on
no they will have to give me the mini
led and they will have to give me an 8k
television with every uh every slide has
to be
hdmi 2.1 and they will have to show me
they will have to
have a technician like we are out here
let me point out tcl i ain't that
expensive
that's fine man if i'm not picking it up
that's okay let's go
hold on i switched off
gaming is the reason why i'm alive
coming home and playing games with my
boys on next-gen consoles was what kept
me
focused absolutely man so glad to see
you home i see that uh
uh that your wife uh made you hide the
consoles behind the tv
just not feeling the monoliths that they
were salute to him
good to see him he's fighting his fight
came back good that's what's up man but
we gotta move on um
yeah best of luck shout out to brad
sam's and dorat
you know what i'm saying.com so yeah
he's got the first break to my attention
for king's topic i'll set it up for him
you know so it looks obviously with both
of these consoles there has been some
issues you know on both sides initially
and i know one they said it microsoft
with the fake vape sort of smoke
whatever that
and then um to click in dvd drive with a
disc is it
but it looks like there has been some
issues that are starting to get reported
with the playstation 5
and looks in reference to gospelly to
the gpu and artifact it
so there's been some examples and it
looks pretty i don't know if you saw a
song it looked pretty
pretty it's pretty spooky but it looks
like uh if you've ever played assassin's
creed you know the part where it where
it used to load because we don't get
words anymore where it used to load in
your way
in like in the animus and you have the
glass flying a little bit
yeah that's the glitchy segments yeah
glitches
yes so called the bright like a sizable
number of users on twitter
are reporting gpu artifacts playing
their consoles while this does not
appear to be
super widespread yet it is more than
just a handful and um they're saying
that
they don't know if it's the gpu as far
as being defective or it's just a bad
yield of the chip overheating or
damaging during shipment
so this has come detention i think king
wanted to talk about this okay this is
your topic sir
set it off hey guys guys
guys hey guys lord king david here
with a public service with a public
service announcement
and i'm here to bring your attention to
some things that have been going on in
our community
now i told you guys earlier
i told you guys earlier when mark cerny
told you
that the cpu will lower itself
so the gpu can rise in taxing areas
and when less taxing areas the gpu will
lower
and the cpu will rise to give you the
fidelity
that you need please send me your ears
he wants you to send you his ear so you
can't hear the bs that's coming out of
his mouth oh my god
all right let me tell you when i heard
that
nobody on this planet will buy a pc
that lowers itself and raises itself
during taxing times mm-hmm i said that
so what you're saying
is it was an unstable boss yes yes yeah
we're gonna get to that part right there
that's the tsl gpu and cpu condo
playstation 5 near you man it's going to
come with a big box and a fire
extinguisher
those are those gpus and cpus they got
open box you know what i mean
it's a recipe for disaster you're
asking for something to happen in an
unstable juggling box
it has to juggle yes so
when i told y'all this before you said i
was capping
then when we saw that the information
came out that they was having terrible
yield rates
you said i was capping y'all said
bloomberg was capping
everybody
getting the facts now
damn near every person that i know
that has a playstation and a lot of you
guys that's on my timeline that aren't
speaking up because you're like oops i'm
not giving him no ammo
have experienced something in some form
or fashion with the playstation
there's a reason why the heatsink is the
size of my monitor
there's a reason why they got a giant
fan in there the size of an oscillating
fan in your room
there's a reason why they decided to use
liquid coolant there's a reason
why for all of that stuff
and everybody would say but king xbox
having problems too
xbox is a stable box so whatever you're
seeing that's happening right now
is probably some anomalies and some
things and you want to tell me so
you will have you will have fault it's
like lightning strikes twice in the same
spot right now
well it's not because it's not in that
same manner
because i have it's the same amount of
friends that i have that have an
ex no issues
is it called a duty thing that's
brick-and-place
i will say that in terms of you know
this twitter presence that i've noticed
personally
that there seems to be a lot more issues
on the playstation side but
i can't look my my brother he's got an
xbox series x and
he he'd be playing a bunch of games and
it just shows it shuts off randomly for
no reason
he was playing halo wars 2 30 minutes
into a game and
xbox just restarts hmm
continue okay well
i told you guys this will happen and
it's not something that i'm taking uh
joy in at all because i have a
playstation
and i told you what happened to me so
all i'm talking about is
should they should they do this because
i heard this
recommended before
down clock it back to its original gpu
specs
of 9.6 teraflops that it really
it really is a 9.2 or 9.6 teraflop
machine
instead of trying to boost it trying to
catch up to god don't don't try to catch
up god lead god up there let the 12 tire
flop
fly up there and you do what you do best
stay in a tcl lane know what you do
don't overclock the box because these
gpu issues will
linger this whole generation until they
get a pro box
and this is how sony
trips up bumps their head on the wall
and wake up in segaville just
just to be clear your your feeling here
is because of this overclocking this
this is what's causing this fun they're
trying to do too much
and uh this is a the source of the
problems
can you can you okay turbo lasts in your
car
for a couple of seconds right because
they know
if you keep holding on that turbo button
your car will blow up
so they got turbo turned on all day
so at some point in time your
playstation
gonna blow up oh my god
it's like yo you know what i acknowledge
it too every playstation has a little
star track enterprise
inside and everyone has a captain kirk
that says
we're going to warp speed eight mr sulu
let's go
i'm giving all she got captain i don't
think she can think anymore
and then
i don't have a playstation file so i
can't really speak on it but it's
i'm i'm going for it you're right i am
looking for
i'm looking for and i hope you know
knock on wood that won't happen to me
uh i don't know if it is what king is
saying it could be early adopt
adoption you know what i mean like
that's always issues with that but if it
is what he says that's that's wild
um i might have to wait for that ps5 pro
you know real talk that happens that
dude i do see it though because you see
celebrities posting it
as well that happened yeah i didn't see
that they have an issue
yeah your favorite game uh one of the
elite people
fc violin his name's luke smith he he he
said not
only did his his council brick he was
having a hard time
getting the the game out david sews out
so he can get a new one with the game
oh man see what happened he had the yeah
he has to uninstall uh
you know y'all games i definitely yeah
all he had to do
was um
lift his joint up and then slide it out
because remember you got to break it
down
so is it made to be broken into me to
your playstation and get your game out
of there
for me though i think i think it's still
early i mean king might you know he
might have a point but i think it's
still early especially
especially because not not too many
people have it because you know
a whole bunch of casters just have you
know all these consoles and then
hopefully not no one's going to buy them
because you know
they're buying violent evaluation but
we'll see man
and it turns into a crazy rash all right
so
when we started singing red ring of
death pop up that's true that's good and
dudes was like oh that's an isolated
incident oh god
oh god my box
my precious box oh god man it says sony
about the for every ps5 saw they got a
fire extinguisher with it oh my god
2.45 million no brother
they sold 1.2.5
and they had to replace 1.2 points did
you say last week they saw
200 thousands yeah yeah you know listen
whatever there is
out there hey but
but i gotta i gotta roll out brother i
appreciate i know we go low
look man absolute present bro to have
you in the realm finally
long overdue little fc the vitamin g
podcast vet tremendous gaming history
absolute pleasure brother where can they
find you what you got going on man
first i got to say thank you man i've
been trying to tell coach man try to
tell
you know coach cox put booby in want to
win put booby
in i was ready we we have a
we have a guest list and you are you
were on top
telematics
you know what's funny he's preparing his
entire personnel to come on and guest on
this show listen
i've been waiting i've been a big big
fan of jaws i always shout you guys out
oh man this is the dopest podcast on
sundays
by far bye none thank you y'all keep it
y'all keep it real y'all keep it
you know in the realm shout out to
everybody in the podcast man
king addict i mean my god solve yo
i gotta get y'all on vgp man y'all could
take a little heat yeah yeah i mean
i love to come back
the good thing about nfc's is is you've
been properly introduced so it's easier
to get you on the show listen man
i said i got a call for my man i really
appreciate what he's doing because again
what i like is respectful debate the
multi-platform approach
everybody gets their say you're not
coming at it from one side
you know what i'm saying and i love what
the brother is doing so it was only a
matter of time it was like we got a
little
we got a little popular but by the last
time i had spoke to you
and i was like all right but i can't i
got to come back because they can't
think i'm too hollywood and i'm gonna
forget
my boy that's what it was man man you
getting too boozy for me
brother absolute pleasure what day is
vitamin g let him know
yes sir first first definitely follow me
on on twitter fc underscore violent and
you know sub to that channel fc
violent um you know i do my monday
monday
at 7 00 pm eastern time which i think is
a 12
12 a.m for y'all for y'all europeans out
there my brits
uh it's vitamin g gaming podcast it's my
every monday
where like i said it's a multi-platform
podcast we talk about everything
we do we definitely go into debates and
it's it's
it gets heated sometimes but it's all
love those all loves it comes from the
gaming heart man i'm a passionate gamer
doing passionate content appreciate it
that's what it is man definitely sub
help help a brother
let's get that one down
i mean i do want to get back into my
videos where like you said i do
yeah i like i highlighted a lot of
especially on the xbox i highlight the
developers give you a little bit of info
the biographies about them where they
came from what games they're making i
did a couple playstation ones too
and i think my last one it was from from
software so it's just basically giving
ideas where they came from
how they make their games and and and
you know where they're going
you know going to the future as well so
it's like i highlight developers because
that's the best part where gamers man
i want i like to know where they come
from factual and how they came to where
they be
you know so definitely check that out if
you like my old stuff and then i hope
i'll be bringing something new for y'all
so
check us out man appreciate i appreciate
the chat salute to y'all
smack that like button share this out
and again it's salute iop
already no vgp iop connect you already
know bro
um obviously i don't know if you are
able to post anything send
all your links and stuff on uh twitter
to me and i'll post them yeah we gotta
post that
man all right gotta have a good one man
you already know it's easy
all right man and kang man don't go
after those knees too hard man
you already know i'm taking as she needs
now we lathering them up i
got mario back there on the loop he
getting closer
he wants to get tagged then but anyway
anyways
you already know so yeah man i saw did
you get your balls off with this topic
hold on no no not this one not yet
oh no it's like this
uh i went away dragons with the ten
dollars to chat i told the world for
those that don't know
when you overclock to high on a gpu the
problems you see on playstation
is how gpus act when they are pushed to
high they will not they will need to
down clock in that gpu fast
that we have through kingdom with the
two dots we chat store two women with
the tcl on fordham
thought of king
with the 5 super chat reason why sony
doesn't make pcs is a pc user since
texas instruments days in the 80s
you will kill a pc's lifespan
overclocking for too long
yeah they were caught up i know that
yeah um so
back to like again that's fc violet's
information
actually sub to the channel let's get
them to a thousand man so the boy can
monetize for real
continue yeah man uh i haven't had any
issues thankfully
um so nothing nothing to report so far
now that's like like what fc said about
you know that that
that red ring of death these issues that
people are having are apparently issues
that cannot be fixed with a patch or
download these are things that
again you never want it to be that your
console is not working to the point
where you have to send it back
right like that again so with xbox so
far it has not
it seems widespread it does it does not
seem a couple people
like i see a lot of people on twitter
having issues with that playstation in
terms of
you know it's shirting off yeah you know
and it's not just
call of duty there's a lot of issues
going around and you know i hope that
they can fix it without sending it back
in but
it it is looking a little bit more
widespread than people like to make it
seem
yeah yeah absolutely and that's again
that's the thing like when you're having
certain issues at the you know the first
week or two of your console
and you download patches and it fixes
them cool
stuff like this though it's like it
sucks it sucks because
you're gonna have to sit there and if it
can't be rectified you got to send it
back and you got to go through this
whole process
and and you know i remember in red ring
of death microsoft was
they kind of got they got their system
in place very quickly about getting
people back their consoles quickly
um sony's never been very good about
that story
they haven't i guess so they're not very
good
in terms of customer service and
so if this is something that's more
widespread than we're assuming
uh i feel for people who have to send
this stuff back in because that is just
not
they're not great and you know when you
act over into the equation
i i see it being even worse so um
but again like that that sort of stuff
the up
it is true when you have when you have a
pc
that you're constantly putting into
overclock mode and that one
a laptop that i have does that where
it's like when you want to get the full
the full juice out of your gpu there's a
button you press boop and
everything just everything gets pushed
to its max and that's cool when you're
playing for a game for
you know two hours three hours tops
after a while
you do start to notice hey my my
laptop's a little hot like
it's a little hot like um and you really
should not be pushing it to that extent
the entire time like so you understand
why the playstation is the shape that it
is you understand what has all those
vents
um but at the end of the day both of
these consoles are coming in relatively
hot
i know that both of these manufacturers
did not have the time to put
these both of these consoles to the
rigors of testing that they would have
liked to
before hitting launch right because that
means they would have both delayed it
into 2021
to really put these consoles to their
paces so
you're gonna see in my opinion even more
kind of hiccups than you would normally
with a console launch because it happens
at every console launch
i think you're gonna see them more now
and we're starting to see that
do i god i hope to god none of this ever
reaches red ring and death level yeah i
really do
but at the end of the day um it's
concerning it's concerning because you
paid
and i would be super like for me like i
said i i don't want to even say how much
i pay for my playstation
if that happens to me
let's see let me jump in i mean i hate
you so i'm kind of where you're at
right now i mean like i got my eye open
i'm not a full king red devil right
there but i was
no no i hope not yeah i hope not i hope
it's not know right written you know
look
both consoles have had we've seen some
issues you know i'm saying obviously
with certain games
breaking consoles or certain features
having to be disabled and stuff like
that
you know i to king's point though you
know when you see
artifacting right that does
lead towards you know a gpu in my
opinion kind of issue
but again i just need to see more of it
before i'm sorry all i just noticed
fear leads to hate hate
anger leads to the dark side
alone that's not what i see again chad
y'all gonna put his words on me and i'm
gonna get killed
i see people i see people in the chat
saying like oh it's not as much for sony
as it is
like it this thing is parallel
my thing that i have not seen on the
xbox size for the most part
is console debilitating
issues like they've been people consoles
turning off turning back on restarting
freezing
nothing that's fully debilitated the
console well i'm not going to say
nothing
but not as much as i've seen on the
other side yeah i mean if i again it's
just
not in the chat because he's going to
kill him i always put up yeah well how
is it pronounced is it ants
or is it i always butcher it anecdotal
anecdotal i always butchered that word
anecdotal see i got my band with me so
anecdotal evidence from what i've seen
is that you know it seems to be a little
bit more skewed to
the playstation 5. shout out to uh solid
rev i've seen him have some major issues
you know i'm saying shout out to a what
is his aeg addict what's his name um
hcg acg yeah you know i'm saying luke
smith i've seen some prominent people
his review his review unit just stopped
working entirely
so i can only go by what i see am i at
that point
to be honest we had luke smith solid red
acg well-known individuals that have
problems and let me tell you something
what about the con
of this tied to this middle line cognito
what about the common man that doesn't
have a voice
what about the guy who can't scream to
the top of the mountain who's not on
twitter
who can't scream sony has screwed me yet
again
i have still seen i've seen more issues
on their side yes but i'm not at the
widespread
oh lord it's it's red ring yeah i'm just
not i got my eye open though
i got mine so that's you better have
your extinguisher ready
i open it and extinguish it so like i
said that that's pretty much it that's
all i got on it
let's move on in any chance before we
move over to the last one and we get out
of here
uh no i think we're good all right cool
i mean
yeah baby this is attic man we got some
uh yeah making people holler with a lot
of patches going on you want me to set
it up when you got it
i could set it up so uh i i could set it
up now
they first off like i kind of want to
throw this in just a little bit
all right assassin's creed von holland i
i wasn't really
playing it before they got this recent
patch
but what i've been told and i think
digital foundry confirmed
is this patch made the series x version
better than the playstation i have no
idea how that happened
so we talked about that just a small but
the biggest thing i want to highlight
is we had a lot of concerns over the
series s like a lot of concerns
including myself but
it looks like with just one patch they
made assassin's creed von hall a 300
console run at uh at 60 frames and
and and what i want to bring to the
table want to bring to the lords is like
is this give you a little bit more hope
in terms of this hardware do you think
that we'll see stuff like this more
often
or do you think that you know this is
that one and done thing
yeah guys let's get started man what you
feel i mean this is
this is ac man ac usually
is one of those games that is
traditionally not
like crazy buggy like broken buggy right
um
except for ac unity because remember
when ac unity came out
you had the disgusting ripped off face
the hannibal lecterface
um you had a bunch of different things
with ac unity it was a new engine
whatever
so ac games generally tend to
function fine but they have their issues
in terms of performance they have their
issues in terms of
uh you know weird glitchy stuff but ac
games are essentially rpgs now
they're huge rpgs um so
i imagine seeing this sort of up and
down up and down with patches
for at least another couple of months
until they settle in
and both uh both of these machines are
running at at
some level of parity um so i can
i imagine the next one whatever they
broke on playstation this time will be
fixed
and and and it may break something on
xbox again it's just the way it
is like i don't i'm not it's obviously
they're going to do these comparisons
right it's going to happen
um but honestly to really look at it six
months down the line is a good time to
really look at and be like okay both of
these games are
are stable now let's see where they're
at in terms of their performance
that's that's what really makes sense
we're not going to see that but
that's what really makes sense to really
get an idea of where these games are
going to be at
in this in my final form right look let
me jump before okay
to me um i really
was up i was actually more upset about
the series
s than i let on like i never really got
a chance to speak on it
because i was i'm gonna be honest i in
my mind i'm not a developer but in my
mind i was like why is that not hitting
60
like it didn't make any sense to me so
then when we got more information
on on the kids and stuff coming out late
and yeah because i'm like
there's no way that can't do it in my
mind you know what i'm saying
and that to me when addict told me about
this news i was like yo
this is what i'm talking about that
needs to have a 60 frames per second
more so to me that's a huge
victory now to saw's point you know with
the whole
you know um you know one patch it it
made the
the xbox series x you know a little
outperform a little bit better than the
playstation 5 now
or what have you but you know this
there's still
two right there's certain places yeah
across the board
across the board it's certainly still
playstation 5 still outperforms
it but we still have the issues with the
screen tearing i guess it's minimized in
some errors but
it's not all the way going and i agree
you know that
a shout out to fonz i think what fonzo
said in the rdx like we should not have
to have
dope tvs with you know
exactly we should not have to resort to
that to resolve the issue you know
i know king does not agree but you just
saw my face right i was like
baby listen man one would like to get
the masses who don't have those tvs to
be able to
save up for them you knew it was coming
this is not something that just popped
out
they didn't just drop an xbox and you
didn't know it was coming for a year
so if you put away fifty dollars a week
you would have definitely had that tv
of what we speak no brother i will not
take that
i don't hear that cx what is it like
screen tearing is a new
thing that only these tvs can fix like
no no no no you know what sovereign
first of all i'm allowing you to stop
i'm going to allow you to stop
because you are a video and an
audiophile you
always gamed on the highest fidelity
except for that one time you got that
high scan
and you learned your lesson so at this
point in time sir
i will think you should walk away from
that ledge because you don't play in
that same little you don't pick your tvs
up off the floor
so at no point in time i i don't want to
hear you
if you tell me that it's something that
you could fix in software
which has been done in millions of games
like don't tell me i need the
accessory to fix this like it's not an
accessory
it's it's we're it's what we do this is
the way
like you won't really stop like we're
really going to be on
this thing you know you know because i'm
on some real mandalorian joy just this
friday was
outstanding yes um i heard i heard yeah
it was outstanding
but sovereign we have been doing
this for sure forever
like literally this is ingrained in us
our television purchases
is really most of the time based on our
console selection
remember hdmi and we had to make sure
that we had enough hdmi
inputs in our tvs so this is not
new stuff for us so a lot i'm telling
you
for some dudes this is a system shock
when they walk in and they be like okay
so i need a tv that has hdmi too oh come
over here sir
what about these on the floor no those
are tcl sir
leave that alone come over here over
here to the wall
to the wall all right so we're looking
at this right here
this cx right here is definitely what
you're looking for
this is uh will bring you to the next
gen you're talking about the playstation
5 and xbox yes
yeah okay so what we're going to do is
this is 2100 excuse you
this is 2100 and this is 65 inches
yeah do you have a payment plan yes
yes yes we do yes we do we can get you
into this let me go let me get more in
in the weeds let me talk technical talk
now right
that 1500 to 2000 cx
has a problem with gamma shift when you
enable vrr
now that that would piss that would piss
me off that all of a sudden
my beautifully calibrated tv when i
enable vrr all of a sudden
black levels are all off the crazy you
can't fix
you can't fix it so i'm gonna have to
eat that if i buy a cx i'm gonna have to
eat that
is that acceptable that's not acceptable
not to me
so what about the new samsungs the new
saying the thing about the same i'm not
feeling that lack of adobe
i'm not like hey that bothers me
that they just don't bend the knee to
dolby
that that really bothers me so it's like
there's there's concessions to be made
everywhere
my beef with this is that screen time
you can get it you can
get a tlc and just you know game and
don't worry about what's happening
because you ain't gonna see that screen
tearing anyway
it will run fast enough to see the
screen tearing anywhere that's great so
you ain't gonna see it anyway so it is
what it is
shout out to tcl for doing it for you
god bless
ridiculous good good so i mean that's
pretty much it so that that was it like
it's like ever
you have concessions even in the highest
of the high end
and it's just like well it's to me this
is a thing that should be fixed in
software right
this the game should fix this like you
know what i mean
so uh but again like i said these games
when you're thinking about all the
platforms that this game is on and they
have to worry about patching all of them
like it's a lot i know ubisoft is built
for this they
this is what they do they release you
know 10 versions of a game at a time
this is what they do
um but either even so like it's not
going to matter like ac is going to take
months to be in a place where everyone's
happy with it
right it's it just is it is what it is i
mean that's like i said that that was my
whole thing and again
you know they got to get the screen
tearing thing down they've got to knock
that out
and hopefully like i said they will
continue to improve upon this game but
for me the biggest take out of this
was series s thank you 60 frames thank
you
but uh king your take sir let's get all
these super chats yeah get the super
chats get super chat
hold on so we have
stitch with the five dollar super chat
shout out to those fake 4k tcl users you
know
you know y'all that's the book of x and
we had kids move with the five dollar
super chat ac valhalla is game of the
year
then we have jd gamer with the 10 super
chat if this is the performance we're
getting in the early days of ps5 what
are we going to get two years from now
when games really stretch the console
these seem to be hardware issues versus
software on the xbox and
and that's the thing right you have very
you have less hardware based stuff on
the xbox apparently at this point
um so then we have one away dragons with
the ten dollars we tag
uh gamespot website reported that uh
they had five ps5s go down
in their office but the worst part is
when your system goes down we can't get
a replacement
that's the issue and clowns on twitter
making fun of
of it is toxic yeah like don't ever be
happy with somebody's console
breaking that's that's crazy that's
horrible that's horrible
but the thing is we're not in the
position as a consumer
that a lot of these guys that you know
the media people whatever
they can contact sony and they will get
one quickly like they don't
because they don't want anybody on their
channel talking
reckless about their playstation's
broken for very long like they're going
to get you a brand new console
um not just not so for the consumer the
consumer has to wait through all these
channels and this
um it's like like telling somebody yo
don't laugh because he tripped and fell
please what is with your hat sir
oh no let's let's let's finish
that we got 108 dragons with the 2 super
chat 8k
baby with no flickering on my tv facts
i have no doubt that we have the wise
old game with the 5
super chat if you're having ps5
performance problems i feel bad for you
son i have 99 problems with my series x
ain't one savage
there we have jd gamer with the five
dollar super chat shout out to the wise
old gamer for the best super chat of the
day and yes
gaming has always been an expensive
hobby eighty dollar cards from way
back yes yes sir as the hobby it is not
for everyone that's for sure then we
have pixel bit g with the five dollar
super chat
oh the c10 has other issues at 4k 120
freesync be acting up
cutting edge will cut your butt oh no
you got to hold on who said that you got
to disable that
shout out whoever i got the cx i would
just put on to that because it already
has the um what you call you you got to
disable that
and then push six says and then educate
the man because uh yeah he put me on
it's kind of a redundant thing you don't
need both technologies you already got
the vr so you're good
so you just stay with that
king has the tcl sponsorship on the low
all this free publicity uh
tcl never been talked about this much
before
if anything he got a sponsorship with
like samson or someone he's like i want
you to
slander that company
there we got clutch man with the five
dollar super chat got an x
beat the robots on black friday kept
refreshing each page on each step
even when the deer popped up forgot to
click pick up so thursday
no doubt no doubt congrats man mm-hmm
all right we caught up king europe what
i told you
when you do is get these damn kits what
was gonna happen
you did you did get that right but i'm
still over here looking at these
playstations that's been delayed 2021s
hey that's that's a soft launch i mean
when i quoted you dudes it launched
yourself or so
i appreciate that microsoft came out be
like oh oh no we'll address this like
we're gonna
oh really okay we're gonna we'll see
what's going on like
it's a real thing you know the narrative
at the very least is not good so let's
let's address this as quickly as
possible so
patches went out and lo and behold
little man 60 frames little man
look a little man move like that 500 box
you got
little man little man
so everybody was sitting there saying
man yo that ass ain't worth the man
that s ain't worth the man
i ain't gonna spend no money you know s
man that's gonna be nothing man
shout out the little man doing all he
can
blue man out here balling for real
yo i told you they got the tools now
so all they gonna do is hit a button and
update and give you a patch and then
you're gonna look over like
oh my god oh my man
they're taking it serious bro it ain't
no update no patch for you
ain't nothing nothing well you're gonna
get an update and your playstation is
gonna down clock your joint to normal
spec
respect that it's supposed to be listen
it's going to get crazier
as the tool sets get better
and me wearing this tribalism
xbox hat let me know this is my scarf
this is my xbox call from fan fest if
you're a fan
you've been to fan fest you know exactly
what you got
where playstation stuff i don't know
anyway you gotta buy it's in the store
um
but again that one patch
and i don't hear nobody on my timeline
talking about outperforming
nothing that one patch
smacked you in your mouth he was running
your lips your king yo buddy what's
doing
that's the patch patch your mouth
scratch your mouth
not all of y'all are quiet in the bushes
scared that a patch is gonna come out
for those games like dirt
what's gonna happen when the patch come
out for dirt
all you do is get smacked around see
it's best right now just to shut up
let the patches hit and y'all go back to
being second place
but i'm having fun here the little man
is out here
oh you can't ain't gonna feel good so
everything gonna be waiting for the
patch now that's gonna be the neutral
link for the fetch no my thing is if
your joint is outperforming wait for the
patch
and then you won't and then and then
think about it this
if we outperform you now and they we get
a patch then
oh god the gap gonna be even big oh god
it's just gonna get worse for you as the
time goes on it's it's just it's a
progressive beating
you know you ever had a boxer that is a
slow starter
and then when he starts to warm up by
the end of the fight the dude head is
all swole up like
where did that happen that i didn't even
notice that he just started accumulating
the beatings
yeah listen they'll fight they're gonna
throw in the towels son
they're gonna throw in the towel look
man at the end of the day yes the patch
definitely improved
the series x um you know there's still
some concessions that had to be made the
resolution
there to bring some stuff down or
certain things but look we get to 60
they got to fix the screen taren and um
you just like to see them continually
improve the game but for me again series
s
big victory that's all i got do we got
any super chats when we get to this poll
and get up out of here because it's
definitely all right
oh my god
lucious augustus with the two dollars
look at this poll popping new ilp poll
with the latest interview by
phil spencer discussing his disdain for
console
tribalism how do you feel in regard to
its place
in gaming the choices are a it's okay to
have pride in your preferred
platform b competition
is good except for personal attacks
or c i don't care i'm not for all this
losing kumbaya talk
that is the question those are the
answers please rock the eye people when
it goes up on twitter shout out to my
man fc
violet who pulled up in the realm long
overdue please subscribe to the channel
check him out vitamin g
podcast his information is in the
description and also will be it's also
in
the chat that addict put it there
earlier please salute but we got the
lords
in the room let me uh what's up say
something real quick all right
first off obviously you guys know if we
uh we treat our members on
youtube right i put something on the the
patreon so definitely go over there and
answer that question over there
i think we're about eight members away
from the new emo so keep that in mind if
people want to join the realm and get a
new email
uh i i definitely want to appreciate
everyone for coming on we had like
almost
450 60 people in the podcast today
you definitely hit that like button you
guys you have no idea how much uh you
know the interaction we appreciate that
and we'll see you
i'll see you next week absolutely
especially when vanessa yeah hit home
with me because he was like yo i was
there
but you guys had the 15 and dirty like i
used to rock with y'all so that's a
little man right there
lord solve look at it if i find what you
got going on sir
first out big shout out to fc i i
remember when fc used to be in the chat
back in the day and
i don't know how i wasn't following him
but i'm bad
about keeping up with other people's
stuff you know that i don't i don't
be on twitter i like like that so i have
my thesis the fc i get
them to follow but i was like i know i
remember fc from before so why i'm not
but anyway so uh guys check me out today
later on today you know i'm never on the
other podcast
i got snatched up so okay at 4 00 p.m
eastern time
on flemish the positive game famous okay
xp podcast 4 p.m eastern time on uh
youtube let me actually i'll put the
link in here that's what's up
yeah i'm going to be on that outside all
of us outside
i already got a couple of things popping
off of my christmas vacation
i was in the dungeons
no doubt yeah so that definitely i'll be
on that so i'm gonna
grab some grub and then get ready to go
i'll go right back in the mix you
already
know lord king lot from you to take
a lot of information spewed
we're gonna pop and provide you what you
gotta go to us sir okay so um
you can find me uh dogcastlex uh fridays
at nine p.m
where weekly we do a raffle for a brand
new statue so you're not getting
nobody's used statues you're getting
statues that's brand new in the box
ship from xm studios so uh
i think i probably have three i gotta
check my phone i think i probably have
three raffles
uh left it's 25 i know a lot of times
you guys win and then somebody tells you
oh you got to pay shipping or you got to
pay tax no it's 25
you get a number and hopefully you win
um
and that's for the black cat uh statue
kos
is going up on tuesday uh this week i
had a lot of stuff happening y'all could
see some boxes and stuff right there
uh i'm changing my display actually i'm
getting ready
to run out now and change this display
um going to shift away
completely away from dc characters
so most of these stuff is going to go
into the buy sell trade groups on
facebook
and on ebay um
because uh being that we have this
collaboration with xm
got you um i'm
i have a ton of xm statues gotcha so uh
it's more of a visual marketing thing
and it changes the way that you operate
sorry that's how it is that's the facts
you know um you know when somebody's
putting money in your pocket and
they uh they're telling you how to move
i got to wear nike's
you got to put your two
to clarify just to clarify it it's a
problem if i'll sell out for a game
okay so you sell out for a sixty dollar
game i'm selling now for a thousand
dollars a statue
okay okay okay you'll be acting like
that's a huge difference
we gotta get tcl to pull up i would love
them
to shut up and listen
somebody at tsa get tcl on the line
my friend is he comes to me for tv
advice right but he is not
he wants like a 75-inch television to
mount as well so
you know this is there's a price range
limit right so obviously the price range
limits for that size
you're looking at v0s and tcl right so
the top-of-the-line tcl
is like it has like four eight you know
hdmi 201 ports it has vrr none of the
stuff that he cares about because he's
only going to watch tv and movies he
doesn't care about games
um and it's like what like like
that people are asking in the chat like
adam said you know how to get in the
raffle they want to get
yeah how'd he get in the raffle all
right hit me on twitter if you follow me
on twitter kingdavidotw hit me on
twitter
and um then i'll give you my paypal and
you just send the 25
and make sure that you watch dolph
castle uh x every friday at 9 00 pm
to get in like see this statue that's
behind me right now and it's the lighter
feature
hopefully y'all can see the light up
feature that's on the uh the gunshots
um i'm a huge fan of gotcha man what
i'm a huge fan of battle of the planets
i'm a huge fan of geforce so whatever
name that y'all know
of this next kos
is going to knock your socks off because
i'm going to give you the law
uh on g-force i'm going to give you the
name changes and stuff like that
but i'm also going to tell you because
remember my stuff is comic book based
i'm going to give you my greatest comic
book
of g-force and the most
unlikeliest um
pairing that they did that you guys
don't know about so i'm going to go
real deep into this pause uh this
is this kos but then the next two kos's
is going to be the most incredible kos's
that you have ever seen
this these two statues i got oneness in
the back right now the other one comes
on tuesday
my god i i i couldn't sleep last night i
could not sleep last night
because i kept waking up with this face
like
that the evil yeah you couldn't sleep
because you're trying to figure out
where to put all this non-accident
stats oh no no no listen
like when no lie literally when i put in
the buy sell trade group they go like
that
literally so because i'm like you're
selling the statues
yeah yeah put them in what the hell is
wrong with you boy you're crazy that's
a that's that's that's uh like ten
thousand on that one
like are you you you you have to get rid
of them i thought you just didn't have
to have them out of france oh no i'm i'm
i'm going away from jesus
to do these type of transformations bit
all of them all of them bye bye
see you later and you're gonna see that
shelf that's over there you gonna be
like oh my god i can see why
shout out to xf studios baby yeah man oh
please listen
i want you guys whoever's left in the
group please share it out
300 um and and you know hit the like
share it out
even if you hit a dislike share it out
to your friends maybe he like it he got
better taste in you
but also go to lords of gaming.net and
check out all these
listen man we have a ton of serious
writers all right serious writers please
go check them out support them
but also watch law incognito and ibontis
on the last word they have tied the uh
what is it ty the tie guy
yeah yo
i almost peed on myself at two segments
in there
and they are so amazing these guys are
working so hard
and they're bringing you staples of the
destiny community and developers
yo listen please go check out the last
word just give it a shot
just listen watch uh however you consume
it but just give it a shot real quick
appreciate it trust me i need you to
listen to it just for one set of
information yeah
did a bunk just beat that rain you know
i watched it beat the raid he bought me
the raid yeah
because if he didn't
yeah appreciate that king man definitely
really feeling the support for our last
word it's been lit and of course lords
of gaming.net which we already plugged
we're gonna plug it again dizzy i but
see i got a meeting with the writers
after this so i got to get out of here
soon but look man again thank you for
having coming through
we got subordinates cooking up probably
something fun at the end of the year
attic right
between me uh hosting wise we got
something
yeah we we we got something uh pretty
much a community podcast coming up at
the end of the year
normally we have two weeks off but
because you guys have been so good to us
we're gonna have one week off this week
this year because
that that second week that we normally
have offer we're gonna do one show
with this so i appreciate it shout out
to philly last word friday was a good
conversation called
jeff thank you it's stinging he said i
can't get a desi i may need [ __ ]
look man game pass i'm coming september
8th so you already know to hit me up
yeah i see
y'all gonna see me online more than ever
when that the 60 frames come but look
that's what i got other thing is
big fun guests cooking some fun guests
cooking
me and i got some stuff i can't wait man
and top of the is gonna be fun too look
everybody enjoy your sunday that's all i
got unless everybody got something else
out of here
make sure make sure you go to that
patreon it's up now yeah it's up now hit
that page y'all see y'all next week
first one to answer
um
so
you